imagine if Lewis Hamilton looked at
airton Center 30 years ago when he first
got in a car and he thought I'm never
going to be as good as that and Center
like we'd never have you know seven time
world champion rather than looking at it
and going I can never achieve that look
at it and go well they've done it so can
I now I know that we have a lot of
people listening to this podcast who
potentially want to start their own
business someday maybe even today or
tomorrow and so this interview is with
Robin Waite Robin is a professional
business coach he's also a public
speaker and he's an author he previously
built and sold a web design agency and
is also building a software company on
the side get out there and sell
something for some money and see how you
feel about it afterwards it's as simple
as that you'll learn 90 of everything
you need to know because within having
to do that you had to Market because you
had to make somebody aware that you had
a program to sell or that you had a
lawnmower to push around somebody's
Garden or whatever it might be this has
been one of my favorite episodes of the
podcast and Robin's book take your shot
was one of the books I think I read it
in like 2020 or 2021 and it featured in
my top 10 books that I recommended that
year the reason why I wrote the book is
because I know that there's some smart
people out there who read the book learn
what they need to do they'll go out
there and they'll just execute it and
then I went to deliver a talk in front
of about 60 people and somebody asked me
what's the thing that stops people from
achieving their goals and I said fear
basically business owners need to fear
the little things in life business ever
so slightly less that stop them
achieving their goals hey friends so
before we get into the episode I've got
some very exciting news that I'm finally
able to share with you and that is that
I have written a book now if you've been
following the podcast for a while you'll
probably know from some of my
conversations with authors in particular
that has been quite the journey over the
last three years this has been the
single hardest thing that I've ever done
in my life but after three years it's
finally here and I'm delighted to
announce that my book feel good
productivity is now available for
pre-order it's going to be published
later this year and you can find a link
down in the video description or if you
head over to
feelgoodproductivity.com all one word
you can check out the website and the
website is absolutely sick now the
central idea for the book came from a
realization that I had while I was
working as a doctor a few years ago and
trying to juggle everything with my
YouTube channel and my business and I
kind of realized that the secret to
productivity isn't discipline it's in
fact joy and sure hard work and great
and willpower and determination and all
of those things are good in small doses
but for most of us they tend not to be
the sustainable route to consistent
productivity but I realized through a
lot of experimentation and then diving
into a bunch of research that actually
the secret to productivity that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
is to find a way to make your work feel
good to find a way to make it feel
energizing and enjoyable and if you do
that you'll be more productive in your
work but you'll also have way more
energy to give to the other things in
your life that matter to you and this
isn't just my own personal experience
but it's an idea that's been validated
by a bunch of studies in the fields of
Psychology and Neuroscience as well and
so the writing process of the book over
the last three years has involved
reading hundreds of research papers
interviewing academics and experts in
the fields of like psychology and
procrastination and motivation and
spending years trying to condense it
into a format and cut out all the fluff
and try to do it in a way that's like
engaging and actionable at the same time
so that's what the book is about it is a
science about guide on how to do more
what matters to you in a way that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
and if you enjoy this podcast then I can
basically guarantee that you will love
the stuff that's in the book there are
nine chapters each chapter has six
different experiments in it that you can
try out in your own life and so there
are 54 different experiments strategies
that you can apply to your life starting
from as soon as you read the book and
the idea is that you apply these and you
see if they work for you and over time
you'll build your own feel-good
productivity system now if you do decide
to pre-order the book then that would be
awesome because firstly it helps me out
and secondly I think the ideas in this
book can be genuinely life-changing and
if you pre-order the book it will be
delivered straight to you on release
date later this year or to your Kindle
or your audible account and I'm
narrating the audiobook by the way how
or to their hardback hardback version of
the book If you prefer to read physical
copies of books and if you do pre-order
then please do be sure to save your
receipts because I'm going to be
announcing a bunch of really exciting
pre-order bonuses exclusively and only
for people who pre-order the book and so
final thing before we get into the
episode is just want to say a massive
thank you to you guys by watching the
videos by subscribing on social media by
listening to the podcast you have made
this book possible without you guys
supporting the channel and everything
that I do there's no way penguin would
have come knocking and been like hey do
you want to write a book and so I'm like
this has been like such a rewarding
experience and I could not have gonna
come to this point without your support
so I just wanted to say massive thank
you from the bottom of my heart for that
so that's it from me do check out the
book If you like at
feelgoodproductivity.com it'll be linked
Down Below in the podcast description
and the show notes as well but now let's
get into the podcast episode itself
alright Robin thank you so much for
coming on the podcast
um you are according to your bio a an
author and also a speaker and also a
business coach
um you're the author of this very good
book take your shot which I read a
couple years ago and shared the [__] out
of on my email list because I just
absolutely loved it
um but I thought we'd make this episode
about the business coach stuff so what
is a business coach firstly yeah there's
a there's a lot of um common sort of
misconceptions about the differences
between business coach what's a mentor
what's a consultant
um so in my view so a mentor typically
has been there and done it got the
T-shirt maybe they're 10 years ahead of
where you want to be for example if you
if you want to run a business we'll go
and find these find someone who's run a
similar business with a mentor and
they'll tell you what to do a coach in
my view tends to sort of ask well-formed
questions they're not necessarily there
to tell you what to do they're kind of
more of a guide
um and I suppose like my Approach is a
bit of a mixture between sort of
business coaching and mentoring so I ran
the agency for 12 years got that t-shirt
um and sometimes as much as you can kind
of lead a horse to water through
well-formed questions people don't often
get it and sometimes they kind of need
to just be told or shown what to do and
away they go nice so it's like like then
Center and so when you say business
coach like let's say someone is like for
example if I want to if I want to learn
tennis I might be able to read a book I
might be able to watch some online
videos but like if I hired a tennis
coach and I was like look I'm a complete
beginner and I want to learn how to play
tennis they'd be able to help me figure
it out is it the same thing for business
it's exactly the same thing for business
but there's a really important piece
which you kind of missed out there as
well because there's going to be one day
when you kind of a bit lethargic wake up
in the morning and you don't really want
to play tennis that much and so your
coach would be there and I'll like
hopefully not with too much kicking or
Screaming drag you out of bed get you
onto the court make sure that you're
taking the right sort of nutrition and
self-care and things like that and it's
kind of more of a nurturing sort of
process than it is you know just um sort
of giving people a formula and away they
go so so I there's a lot of
accountability which I do with clients
so
um again when you're coaching somebody
typically what tends to happen is you're
inviting them to do something which they
maybe are a little bit too scared to
have they know they need to do it but
maybe they haven't quite got the
confidence to get out there and do it
for whatever reason so it could be well
fear is the obvious one like fear of
failure fear of
um uh fear of success in some cases fear
of
um you know rejection so sales for
example is something we should cover a
lot of because you're going to get an
awful lot of rejection in there and
obviously as human beings we like to be
liked so getting out there and getting
lots of no's doesn't come naturally to a
lot of people yeah and as human beings
we tend to avoid the things we don't
like the things which kind of offer us
discomfort we move towards comfortable
things you know nice nice fluffy pillows
and cushions and things like that so
coach's job uh is really just to like
get people out there slightly outside
their comfort zone I don't really like
that term because if you're too far
outside your comfort zone for too long
it actually has an opposite effect it's
like it's a demotivator at that point so
um so you want to push in just a little
bit outside their comfort zone but
enough so that they can learn through
that experience of doing something new
and then they from there it's it's kind
of easy at that point because they start
to build muscle memory they start to do
things on autopilot and then you get
that really like happy parent sort of
moment where you're like ah like really
proud of like watching your um you know
clients kind of grow and do stuff that
they weren't doing before they met you
nice okay sick so
um we have a lot of people in our um who
who listen or watch this podcast and in
our deep diver Community who are
interested in starting their own
business interested in becoming
entrepreneurs they see the benefits of
the entrepreneurial lifestyle they might
see a business like mine and be like
damn he quit his day job and now it
makes millions on the internet making
videos that seems pretty freaking cool
and I think especially with the whole
cost of living crisis the pandemic
people losing their jobs a lot of people
have kind of seen that hang on the
default path is no longer working the
path where I get a job I go to a decent
unique that lands me a decent job that
lands me promotion after promotion and
eventually I'm happy that default path
no and and I'll be able to buy a house
and stuff no longer really works and so
a lot of people are looking to
entrepreneurship to starting a business
as a kind of way out of the situation
that they're in or a way in to a more
fulfilling life filled with freedom fund
flexibility money impact all of all of
the good things but the problem people
have is that taking that first step and
getting started so I wonder if
can we sort of do a bit of a role play
where I'm a total beginner coming to you
as a coach and I'll try and play the pot
and imagine myself how I was a few years
ago potentially and you kind of coached
me through the process is that
reasonable yeah we could do that okay
sick so I'm gonna be like right Robin
I've heard you know I heard you
another's podcast I've heard you're a
business coach I think I want to start
my own business but
you know it's overwhelming I don't even
know where to begin I've got a day job I
don't yeah help help me what do I what
do I do cool so my first question is why
why okay
um so I am working as a junior doctor at
the moment and it's really grueling and
I thought I enjoyed medicine but
actually now that I'm actually working
in it I'm realizing that spending 40 50
60 hours a week working in the NHS
you know I'm not sure if I if I want to
leave leave medicine but I watched some
available YouTube videos he talks about
the power of having multiple streams of
income preferably passive income and so
I was thinking you know if I could make
an extra 2K a month 3K a month that
would be completely life-changing I'd be
able to go part-time in my in my day job
working maybe two or three days a week
and I'd be able to actually spend time
with my girlfriend who I want to propose
to and we won't have kids but you know I
don't want to live a life where I'm sort
of tied to wage slavery for 60 hours a
week cool okay so my next question is
for you so thank you as well for giving
me all that backstory
um
I suppose I want to get an idea about
how
big a problem is for you at the moment
like how long can you tolerate being
where you are right now
would you say oh okay so I'm like two
years into my doctor career
could you do it for another six months a
year yeah I've got my you know I'm
finishing off my F2 year in about six
months time so at that point there's a
very natural break point but I don't
have enough money to be able to sort of
not work okay and so I'm planning to do
locums and extra shifts and stuff and I
can probably do that for a year or two
but if I continue on that point and if I
really want to go into medicine then you
know the more years you take out of the
thing the harder it is to go back in
yeah
um but honestly if I had to
you know the last six months if I had to
relive those for more than maybe another
six I don't know if I can handle it okay
so and we're and did you say it's sort
of two to three k a month extra is that
what you want to earn or is it two to
three k to get you out of where you want
to be
right now so at the moment I'm learning
about 3K a month okay and I'm thinking
if I can get uh you know if I could have
a business that even makes me 2K that
would be the absolute the absolute dream
it would be so good I'd be able to then
go down to three days a week so down
okay so an extra 2K drop you down to two
week uh two three days a week okay cool
what do you love doing I thought I loved
medicine
um that's no longer it's no longer
entirely the case
what do I love doing I don't know really
I mean not spend time spending time with
family and friends okay I used to play
World of Warcraft back in the day did
you yeah it's interesting
um I guess
yeah what do you mean what what I'm
doing so
when you're I believe when you're
starting a business you kind of need to
um there's three kind of you mentioned
lots of F's earlier on but there's three
F's which are really important to me so
freedom is the first one so to be able
to kind of live life on your own terms
and do what you want to do yeah
um the second one is fulfillment so find
something which you're deeply passionate
about that you jump out of bed in the
morning even if you weren't getting paid
for it you would you would do it anyway
because you just love doing it so much
it just fills you up and then obviously
the third f is finance so we want to
create something for you that gives you
the freedom you want fulfills you and
also pays the money
finances nice okay so for example and
this is where we just throw some ideas
out there and see what sticks okay so
imagine if you could earn an extra 2K a
month
um streaming World of Warcraft that
would be pretty cool yeah that'd be
really cool are there people out there
doing it at the moment there are but
they're so like left like trying to be a
professional athlete or something like
it's such a small percentage of yeah but
they started they did why can't you
I think what's stopping me from
streaming wow is that
I know that there are about a million
people trying to do it on Twitch for
example of which like 10 are making
money so that's like one in a hundred
thousand chances of actually making any
money from it yeah which to me feels
like not great odds okay and ideally I'd
like to start some sort of business
where I feel the odds are more stacked
in my favor okay
what are you good at you know I'm
actually I I think I'm reasonable at web
design okay in that I used to do it when
I was a kid and then I kind of got out
of practice when I when I got to med
school because there wasn't enough time
to do anything
but I always enjoyed that at school and
that was the thing I'd you know I'd get
home from school and I'd be tinkering
away back in the day on like my MySpace
graphic Banner thing and then when
Myspace died and Facebook became a thing
I would design signatures for people's
Forum accounts back on forums or things
you still remember my space yeah I know
I'm so old yeah you know I I you know
this business thing is a Young Person's
game I think I think
[Laughter]
but I used to really enjoy designing
websites and I used to really Tinker
away at my own personal website and I
doubt and I thought about trying to make
money from it but then something always
kind of helped me back and so that's
something that I think I actually used
to really enjoy back in the day so
there's something holding you back
there's there's already a recurring
theme or pattern in here and I wonder
what that might be
what do you think it might be if if I
think okay
I could make money from web design for
example because I because I know that
web designers are a thing and I know
that people do make money from it and I
know that web design agencies are a
thing because I've come across them on
the internet but if I think of it I
think I'm not good enough I think I
don't have skills I think why would
anyone pay me for anything I think even
if I did have the skills how on Earth
would I find people to pay me for
websites
and then I think even if I did do that
is is it actually something that I would
enjoy okay um yeah so all of those
things like perfectly valid
but um how do you know that any of them
are true
what evidence do you have yeah I don't
yeah honestly I don't really have an
evidence for it I think it's just the
fear of like I know my skills in web
design are kind of old now I know that
the Frameworks and stuff have evolved
people are using all this new software
which I don't yet know how to use and
yeah I guess in my mind I'm thinking
it's going to be a way harder hurdle to
cross okay but you thought becoming a
doctor might be hard you did that that's
a good point yeah yeah so you can you're
perfectly capable
yeah I guess the thing with medicine is
that the the path is laid out in front
of you yeah you have a very clear next
step and you know that okay just need to
do this thing and if I just do the thing
and I'm very good at doing the Thing
Once I'm told what the thing is but when
it's when it comes to actually figuring
out the thing and being a bit of a
self-starter that's when I think I I
really struggle so so long as the
pathway's there and it's clearly laid
out and you can see it you're you're
happy with that okay yeah so it's a
little bit like
um imagine you're driving a car at night
you can see the headlights are shining
up the road but they only shine up the
road so far yeah you have faith that the
road is going to keep on appearing in
front of you yeah otherwise like you
just stop dead wouldn't you you wouldn't
go anywhere yeah so that's kind of like
that's the Paradigm that you'll kind of
find yourself in at the moment with the
web design side of things it's just that
at the moment it's dark and the lights
aren't on so we've got to create for you
your equivalent of what that roadmap
looks like to get a web design business
up and running okay so in your eyes how
would that work what would you do
um hang on before we go down the web
design route so aren't there other
businesses I could do like I've heard
day trading is a thing I've heard people
doing paid surveys I've heard yeah
why do you want to do any of that
it's because you see people on Tick Tock
getting rich quick right yeah like the
0.1 percent of people so do you have any
passion for any of those things no no so
don't let's not even go there so it's
okay okay that makes sense I should
start with something I'm passionate
about find something you like enough
that you can get started that when you
are challenged by it that you have
enough impetus to want to carry on and
work through those challenges like you
did with medicine
if you get into things purely like you
have to if it's just for finance if it's
just one of the apps that's taken care
of there'll be a point when it becomes a
bit hard and because you've got no
fulfillment from it it's not really
giving you the freedom you want because
when things start to go wrong you'll
just think you can fix it by putting
more time into it right so now your
Freedom's gone as well your fulfillment
is just non-existent and you're just
doing it for the money like are you
going to carry on for much longer are
you just going to stop
damn right so you need all three F's
they they need to be there to some
degree they might not all be 10 out of
10. right it might be web design there's
a lot of hard work to go into web design
you know it's technical it's there's
late nights there's things like that but
freedom-wise you can sit down at your
computer and build a website whenever
you want you know if you've got kids you
can do it once they've gone to bed you
know if you're doing if you're studying
you can do it around your studies or
just spend a couple of hours a weekend
or something like that so maybe Freedom
wise is like a seven out of ten it's not
a 10 out of 10 but 7 out of 10 and
that's tolerable but fulfillment wise
when you actually sit down to do it you
love it and you're like you get this
creation at the end of the process the
website for a customer and you're like
wow like they're pleased you'll you get
some enjoyment from that you're like a
nine out of ten on the Fulfillment
factor and finances will you know maybe
to begin with you do some websites
for not very much money but to get
reviews case studies testimonials so
initially the finance might be a six but
you can see the potential in it you get
some money on the back end for hosting
and supporting care plans and then
gradually the money starts to build up
so you can actually influence that from
a six out of ten to eventually a 10 out
of 10 over the next year or two
but with what you suggested previously
like if it's just about the money you
can't you can't influence the other two
okay yeah because I guess part of me was
was worrying like
yeah I think I enjoyed web design but to
be honest I haven't done it in like 10
years at this point and I enjoy other
things as well like like we said playing
World of Warcraft watching Netflix you
know I enjoy playing badminton but
I'm pretty unlikely to be a professional
World of Warcraft player not many people
make money for watching Netflix and very
few people become professional badminton
players so it's like
how how much does like I guess a viable
business model imagine if Lewis Hamilton
looked at and Center like 20 plus years
or 30 years ago when he you know first
got in a cart and he thought I'm never
going to be as good as that and Center
like we'd never have you know seven time
world champion any any of the amazing
things out there if you look at it
rather than looking at it and going oh I
can never achieve that look at it and go
well they've done it so can I
yeah and then and then it's about
thinking so that's the future version of
you way off in the distance but the the
future version of Ali in 12 months time
or 12 years time needs today's Ally to
do something so what's the first step
you're going to take
with your web design business
hang on hang on I'm still not sold on
whether it's a web design business
because let's just go with it we can
always change the product later business
is business right
but it doesn't matter what the product
is yeah businesses work the same way the
world over okay so you have the same
function sales marketing Finance the
different functions of a business are
the same no matter what business you're
in okay they're all the same so the
products can change so long as you
understand the concept around how to
productize any kind of a service it
doesn't matter whether it's web design
or videography or podcasting or whatever
you know whatever it might happen to be
yeah
um as long as you get the concepts of it
you can apply the Frameworks to anything
so then how important is it because
because for example I've got a full-time
job I don't have very much time on my
hands and I ideally want to get to this
kind of 2K a month dream world in the
next say six or 12 months yeah so how
important is it that I get the get the
right topic like whether it's web design
or tennis coaching or personal trainer
or like I feel like there are all these
options of making money and yeah I'm
often I think in the past I've been held
back by just seeing all these and you're
not doing anything so
that's true so at least if we do
something we can start to eliminate
stuff
so perhaps perhaps maybe build a
five-page brochure style website for
somebody for a friend family member
doesn't matter
whether you charge them for it or not
don't care but just get out there and
build build a five-page website in
Squarespace and see if you can do it so
if you enjoy it
at least if you do it and you don't
really enjoy it that much
go and do something else let's have
another conversation let's come up with
another idea
okay nice so it sounds like it's less
about like exploring all the
possibilities in abstract before
committing and more about like let's
commit to something that ticks the book
that ticks the three boxes of FFF yeah
fun free no what is it Freedom
fulfillment Freedom fulfillment and
finance Freedom fulfillment and finance
yeah yeah okay
yeah nice mate I'm glad I had a coach
okay so this is good I would have been
like overthinking this [__] for like
years most people do and that's why most
people never start
um there was uh well Mutual um
connection we've got is just set up this
amazing
um sort of not not-for-profit business
help group was Simon Squibb we know we
both know him and um the most common
question which is appearing on his
platform at the moment is is around
funding I need to go I need to get
funding before I start anything and it's
like the the
um I don't know why it is but there's
there's so many people when they haven't
run a business they think that again
doesn't matter what the idea is they
have to somehow go out and get
investment or a loan or something like
that yeah that's what I was thinking
because like Dragon's Den and stuff yeah
you know it's podcast I saw he was on
Dragon stand and I'm like oh you know
he's you've got to get that 100K
investment before you start yeah and
it's it's BS it's it's a complete um
misconception because there is there is
a in any business there is a version
which you can start from the ground up
with no Capital you can just do
something towards you know anything
doesn't matter you can go you can go and
register a domain name you can go and
set up a social media
um like a Twitter account you can get
all these things that you can do for
free
um yet people sit there and go well I
can't get a loan you know I've got ccj
against me I can't get a loan so
therefore I can't start a business well
you're no better off if you take no
literally no steps towards whatever you
know your goal is so people just end up
procrastinating so the question I always
look is you just need to reframe it ever
so slightly you just need to say well if
if funding's off the table it's not an
option what is the first step you can
take towards the smallest First Step you
can take towards getting this business
off the ground what could you do today
and it might even just be get out a
sheet of A4 paper and write down all of
your ideas on it yeah like that's just
doing something at least from that you
can start saying well that was a good
idea or I could charge this for that or
maybe actually I don't really like that
idea maybe I'll do this writing down a
list of ideas on a sheet of paper yeah
um and then across the top of it you can
then put some criteria against it so
this is so again a lot of people get
they like you said you can do trading or
you can do websites you do streaming
it's all these different amazing things
which which you can do in like 2023
right thanks to the internet okay it's a
little thing called the internet but and
again that causes people to
procrastinate because they've got too
many choices again they don't start they
can't decide which one to do so write
them all down and then in the three
columns across the top I think again the
link to the three F's so
um which uh how much do I love this idea
on a scale of one to ten right uh and
the second column is
um if I do this if it's like a business
idea and I do this for clients and what
results You Know How likely is it that I
can get good results for the clients
we'll mark that one out of ten and then
the final one is can people afford to
pay me for this and we grade that out of
ten and you can add in as many criteria
as you want and so each idea then you
end up with a score out of 30 and quite
often cream Rises to the top you end up
with one or two really solid ideas where
they might not all be 10 out of tens but
if you can if you can help somebody and
you're passionate about it and you can
they can afford to pay you for it that's
a solid business idea this episode is
very kindly brought to you by huel I've
been a pen customer of huel since my
fifth year of medical school since 2017
actually since before I started my
YouTube channel and I first started
using heal because my life was pretty
hectic I was juggling lots of different
things like medical school and exams and
trying to sort out publication points
for my future like doctor job
applications and alongside I was running
a business I was building an app and I
was trying to maintain some semblance of
a social life and so he actually came in
really handy for that if you haven't
heard of it it's basically a meal in a
shake that contains all of the
ingredients that are essential to thrive
it's got a perfect balance of protein
and carbs and fats and vitamins and
minerals and these days the heel black
edition is my absolute favorite comes in
nine flavors salted caramel is my
personal favorite and the heel black
edition is particularly good because it
is a higher protein version than the
heel original it was the original that I
was using back in 2017 but the Black
Edition came out a few years ago changed
the game because it's 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get hinge and so I'm keeping an eye on
like my protein intake and it's so nice
that I can get that high protein hit as
the first thing in the morning heel is
also very affordable it comes out to one
pound 68 per meal for a 400 calorie meal
which is actually way cheaper than most
of the other options on the market and
certainly way cheaper than other you
know even Standalone protein shakes like
I said I've been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. my friends literally make
fun of me as to how much fuel I have in
the house and they're like what you have
all this healed I'm like yeah it's
actually so good so if you're interested
in signing up for heal then head over to
heal.com forward slash Deep dive and if
you use that URL a it helps us out
because then they're Keen to sponsor
more episodes but B you get a completely
free t-shirt and a free Shaker with your
order so that is hopefully an incentive
to use heal.com forward slash Deep dive
and actually I interviewed the founder
of huel Julian Hearn on this very
podcast in the very first season so you
can check out that episode if you like
it's got rave reviews really good
episode all about starting and growing a
business so anyway thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you also very excitingly
there's a new feature that they've added
to the app which is a daily interest on
your uninvested cash these interest
rates may go up or down over time as the
economic environment changes but the
cool thing is that you get paid out
every single day if you're into that
sort of thing and so if you haven't yet
started with investing and you want to
give it a go then you can download the
app on the App Store and if you use the
coupon code Ali Ali it will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode let's wave a match Pond and
pretend that it's no longer a web design
business but it's the thing I'm
passionate about is giving relationship
advice to my friends and I would love to
build a business around that awesome and
I'm Keen you know happy to take the next
step in that direction cool are you
doing any of that at the moment uh yeah
so my friend I mean I'm not charging
anyone for it but my friends like all
they all come to me for relationship
advice okay and it's like I love it you
know I get home from a day of work and I
feel trained but when a friend comes
over I'm making him a cup of tea and we
talk about their relationship and I feel
so energized by that awesome how are you
thinking about sort of launching that as
a business just out of curiosity
I know that relationship therapists are
a thing and I even heard I was listening
to one of the Stephen Bartlett's podcast
he had a relationship coach on there
where you don't need a qualification to
be a coach and so that thought I thought
that was pretty good yeah um because I
don't have much time to get a
qualification or something but if I
could build a business around helping
people
get better in their relationships or
feel better about their relationships
that would be really cool yeah
um at the moment I just think I just
think it would be cool I don't actually
know how I would find clients and stuff
so what do you think is that a viable
business we'll come on to that and
you've before we do that you've raised a
really valid point there because there
is a there's a gray there's a line fine
line between therapy and coaching and I
think it's massively important to kind
of point that out and a lot of people
start coaching and then just because
they're enthusiastic and there's you
know they kind of do it for the right
reasons but unfortunately execute it
poorly they start to transgress into
like my belief is when you you don't
need a coaching qualification for
coaching I should say but when it comes
to crossing over into the the Mind Body
Spirit type stuff and it becomes therapy
related work that I believe you need a
certificate for because you're treading
like a very fine line between sort of
mental health issues and physical issues
and things like that so it's really
worth sort of emphasizing that but
um coming back to your idea about
um sort of setting up as a relationship
coach for example so
um
what's what steps would you take uh an
individual through to help them I guess
find a partner or have a better
relationship which approach would you
take what would the steps be okay so I
guess I've helped friends in both in
both camps okay so if we say finding a
partner for example
um I would take them through
oh you know I I've I've I've never
really thought about the steps for this
but I guess I would
find out a bit about them and find out
about their goals and what they're
actually looking for whether they want
to go for something casual or something
serious mostly my friends you know we're
getting into our late 20s we want to go
for something serious
um I would then
help them set up a dating app profile
because I actually think dating apps are
basically the easiest way to meet
someone uh I would help them optimize
that profile cool through because I you
know I'm a nerd so I read stuff about
that I just love reading stuff about
relationships and so you know black and
white photos and like balance between
selfies and professionally professional
photos and what sort of prompts they
should answer and I'm really good at
that like I love going through my
friends hinge profiles and just sort of
revamping them and they love it and they
get good results
um but at the same time I would also get
them to attend meetups or something like
that kind of get partake Parts in groups
and stuff where they can kind of meet
people in a more casual kind of setting
and then once we've done that once
they're on a date then I would get them
to go into it into the date with a few
different mindsets
um and then we'd kind of debrief after
the date and we'd do this a bunch of
times and I basically guarantee that if
they've gone on updates and follow my
method uh then they'll they'll find
someone to be in a relationship with
cool so you've got I couldn't I lost
count of the steps there but let's call
it Ali 7 step you know relationship
method uh sure we could come up with a
better name than that at some point but
see your unique seven step process to
find your ideal partner yeah
um just out of curiosity how long do you
think it might take to and I know it
depends it's going to come into this but
we'll tackle that later but on average
so remember it's on average how long
does it take to go from uh starting the
dating process your seven step process
to the end hopefully finding somebody
and settling down a little bit
would you say I would say
I'd be very surprised if they followed
my steps and went on a date once a week
which is what I advocate that they
wouldn't find someone within six months
six months okay so you have a six month
transformation program where you taken
from single to a relationship following
your seven step process huh right okay
um that sounds pretty good yep yes yeah
and then
um how how so how often would you kind
of meet with them during that six months
would it be like a monthly coaching
session would it be would you meet with
them weekly what do you think you would
how much time would you have to put into
it okay probably
[Music]
probably a sort of two-hour intensive
thing to start off with while we get the
profiles and and all that kind of stuff
and then I think if I met with them once
a week
that would be great for them okay I feel
like would I have time to move yeah I'd
have time to time to meet with them once
a week okay but like once they start
dating then instead of actually a
one-on-one call they could fill out a
thing or well we could do it
asynchronously through WhatsApp voice
notes or something like that but I think
I think I feel like once a week would be
good so it might be an intensive period
for I don't know eight to twelve weeks
for example which is weekly then it
gradually sort of eats out into more of
just a let's catch up yeah so that
sounds good yeah so okay
um
just out curiosity if you had to charge
I don't know let's say an hourly rate
for each session over those 12 weeks
what would that how much would you
charge that's where I feel like there's
a bit of a a hurdle here in my mind
because
like for example I know I could make 40
pounds an hour by taking an extra shift
at the hospital and so I feel
comfortable charging 40 pounds an hour
for that
but when it comes to the relationship
stuff like I don't have any
qualifications yes I've helped my
friends but I feel I'd feel really you
know charting 40 pounds an hour is
charging it to the Healthcare System
it's not charging it to a person so I'd
feel really weird if someone asked me
yeah for my help and I would charge them
40 pounds an hour I'll share a little
story with you so I I met Mrs White
Charlotte uh through a website called
muddy matches uh 11 years ago money
matches muddy matches muddy matches yes
we live out in the Cotswold so it's a
bit oh well yeah very country
um
so
um how much would I
pay to have had the opportunity to meet
my future wife through online dating and
I wasn't particularly good at the dating
game let's be fair
um you can't put a price on that and so
I think where you kind of have looked
inside yourself and kind of looked into
your own value system there and that I'm
not going to give you a therapy session
now about around that but
um it's common what people do is they
kind of base their prices based on their
own value system but what you're
actually doing there is you're making a
decision on behalf of everybody else in
your world all of your clients so when
you say well I think I'm only worth 40
pounds an hour you're kind of making a
decision on behalf of all of your
clients
which might may or may not be serving
them justly
so
think about it this way there are things
where maybe if you haven't paid enough
for it do you really value it that much
whereas actually if you've paid a lot
for something
do covet it cherish it look after it
take care of it think whether if you're
a capitalistic expensive cars and things
like that like you get the slightest
thing you're like oh my God just ding my
car sort of thing so you really cover
things that you actually investing in so
when it comes to coaching especially
it's much better to be at the more
expensive end of it because then what
you get is clients who are invested in
the process they're more likely to do
the things which you're encouraging them
to do and as a result of that they're
more likely to get better results right
so if you're charging 5 to 10K for this
transformation program my goodness we'll
come to that okay okay so just this is
part of the coaching process yeah so
let's say you're charging five to 10K
for this coaching process you're going
to get very committed clients but also
you don't need that many clients each to
work with each year in order to build a
sustainable profitable coaching practice
10 clients a year 20 clients a year and
actually you've got a six figure income
bloody hell right it would take me 10
years of training in medicine to even
approach a six figure income yeah so and
this this is where a lot of people get
business wrong so
um do I want to focus on
let's let's stick with where we're going
with your coaching business for the time
but you know coaching practice
so six month transformation we've got
this intensive 12-week period yeah you
were thinking well 40 pounds an hour I
was thinking like I was thinking like 10
quid an hour because I'm like what the
hell do I know about this okay well okay
even at 10 pound now so for a weekly
session say which is an hour plus all
the different touch points but you're
talking there of like charging like I
don't know 200 quid for 200 pounds for
like a program six month program right
yeah if you think about it yeah that's
pretty cheap okay yeah so this is where
we we break into like people see pricing
as um binary okay so binary thinking so
it's either yes or no a mineral amount
it's too cheap or it's too expensive
okay yep right and at 200 pounds I think
you probably well your face said that's
too cheap I can't believe I was going to
charge that much of my time I'm worth
more than that yeah well you know more
than that yeah I could make more I can
make that in one shift and then when I
said five to 10K your eyes popped out of
your head you know across the table and
and so but what we've got now is we've
got 4 800 numbers between 200 pounds and
5 000 pounds okay yeah and there's
there's a a future version of value
that's again selling his coaching
um program for 5K Maybe not today but in
the future yeah so we we can do do you
wanna we can do you've seen me do this
before I think Ali but the Jedi mind
trick do you want to play a Jedi let's
play the deadline play the Jedi mind
trick game okay so I'm gonna start 200
pounds and the reason I do this exercise
well I'll explain it afterwards okay so
we're going to figure out
um what level you need to be selling
this at as of today if you're going to
step out and work with your first
coaching client okay so 200 pounds five
for the six months yeah for the six
months 500 pounds 800 pounds 1200 pounds
already crikey 1200 quid yeah so you're
so you're you're everybody has a poker
face right for whatever so whenever so
initially when you were trying to figure
this out how much you should charge in
the structure of your program and what
am I worth you're trying to solve it
intellectually yeah okay and we all know
you have without going to woo-woo you
have more than one brain okay yeah
um our subconscious brain is very
intuitive and so
um that's why intellectually were like
200 pounds but when we started to look
into your subconscious of where you
actually truly value yourself you're
like well 1200 well it was between 800
and 1200 pounds where Poker Face came
out and yeah you couldn't keep a
straight face and I knew that that's
where your subconscious was telling you
yeah even though as you say 1200 I'm
just like I find myself just not being
able to give a space it was 800
comfortable
you're not disagreeing with me so so
what we want to do is we want to we
don't want to stay in Comfort Zone
because we don't actually learn that
much in there you've got to stretch
yourself a little bit so my advice would
actually be if you were going to go out
and sell this hypothetical coaching
program sure you'd go and Pitch 10 to 20
people at 1200 pounds for that six month
transformation process
and I I know because I've done this with
700 over 700 business owners now
um the pricing thing that is get people
to elevate their prices I know that a
good conversion rate for most service
businesses like coaching is
somewhere around about one in five to
one and three let's round the numbers
call it 20 to 40 percent really so yeah
so if you pitch ten years
uh it's it's not actually it's 20 so one
in five is actually quite
it's quite low a lot of people think
it's quite low but like how if I if I
think of like
people that I know at work they they
wouldn't pay a thousand pounds 1200 quid
for like maybe they're not your ideal
audience
ah okay because how do I find my ideal
audience oh are we going to come to that
but we can do but um yeah uh the other
way to look at it as well is
um again people approach us from the
wrong way around they go I'm gonna build
my product and then hope that people
come and buy it
right yeah what we actually want to do
is we want to come from the other the
other end of the spectrum okay so if
your goal was to
um make 100k from your coaching business
100 okay
damn okay yeah right but that's okay
what would your goal be if you were
starting from scratch you're gonna give
this a shot if I can make 2K a month so
that's like 22. okay 24K yeah okay so
now what we do is we take 24K we divide
it by 1200 pounds and it's roughly 20
clients
yeah yeah if I had 20 clients could you
service 20 clients do you have the
capacity to work with 20 clients over
the course of a year so if it's weekly
calls that would be 20 hours a week 20
hours a week that's quite a lot it's a
lot coaching yeah very energetic I don't
know if I'd be I'd have the time to do
that yeah do you think work with
okay let's think about this so you know
I work Monday to Friday and some
weekends and night shifts and stuff so
if I had flexibility on one I could book
them because my roto is weird
foreign I think I could do five five a
week five calls a week probably because
that's not like one a day on average
yeah so so what we've done is this this
called capacity based pricing right so
you work out your your end goal for your
business what's what how much money do I
want to make basically it's very simple
terms okay and we divide it by the price
that we've kind of come to a conclusion
this is roughly what I think we should
be charging yeah but now we've got a gap
so if you only get five clients
concurrently
um which probably means like 10 clients
throughout the year because you're going
to get a little bit of overlap a bit of
churn some clients leaving they meet
their future wife husband whatever and
they don't need your help anymore maybe
they come back when they've got
relationship problems further down the
line I don't know
um
but so 10 clients say so actually what
we've established is that you're going
to fall short of your financial goal
because you don't have the capacity to
service 24 000 pounds worth of business
okay so good point yeah the real price
point yeah so this so this is so
capacity hasn't made a go your goal is
important capacity has a major part to
play especially if you're setting this
up as like a side hustle yeah alongside
a full-time job yeah
um so now we've got a difficult decision
here we go well 1200 pounds I know that
was going to be a bit of a stretch but
if somebody can afford 1200 could they
afford two and a half k
probably over six months don't forget if
I could get people at two and a half k
that would mean I would only need 10
clients in the whole year yes
and you could go down to three days a
week and then yeah I feel emotional just
thinking about it and I'm not even like
faking here I'm just like they're just
sort of imagining myself in that
position yeah if I break the fourth wall
a moment I'm just like oh my goodness
that would actually be transformational
but I have all these fears coming up
around like charging 2500 and even how
do I find these 10 people forget about
the money forget about the money can you
can you visualize yourself working with
those people and transform their lives
yes okay yeah can you do you feel
confident enough in your ability to
deliver like such remarkable results for
them that you'd have no problem
refunding them if they had if they
didn't get if they didn't meet the love
of their life and they say they alley
this is rubbish you didn't you didn't
find the love of my life I won a refund
would you have any problem refunding
them if they did the work then no if
they didn't do the work then well they
didn't do the work okay well let's let's
assume they did the work you threw
everything at it yeah best will in the
world didn't get the results no they can
have a full refund I don't want the
money if they don't get the result yeah
100 so there's no de-risk it there's no
Jeopardy here what do you mean oh okay
like if someone doesn't if someone
doesn't get the result yeah I can just
give them give them give them their
money back
provided they've and this is where the
contract comes in okay so the contract
States you've got to show up to all of
the calls you've got to do all of the
homework you've got to go on the dates
etc etc and if they do that and if they
do that I mean they're basically going
to find they can find a relationship and
if they don't know how happily refund
them sure but I want this I'm kind of
Wonder worry won't everyone ask for a
refund
well they won't
yeah if they actually did that yeah like
I've talked to so many of my friends
through this
with way fewer touch points yeah if
someone actually followed my advice
their life would change even if they
didn't find a relationship their life
would 100 change yeah but okay nice okay
so I could it's like okay that's that's
interesting I've I've never thought
about that before I've always been
scared of charging for anything even the
thought of it but the thought that I can
just always refund their money yeah
and and 10 clients over the course of a
year that's less than one a month
yeah right that's one quite doing one
client a month
somebody who's what type of person has
disposable income two and a half K and
again don't forget it's going to be
spaced over six months okay so they
could pay for it all up front if they
want to that's actually okay so that's
like 500 quid a month basically for six
months
who is the sort of person who would have
that kind of disposable income okay so
well firstly all my friends working in
finance yeah all of my friends working
in Tech basically none of my friends
working in medicine but you know my
mum's a consultant psychiatrist she has
colleagues who are trying to get into
dating after divorce after divorce or
something they easily have 500 a month
to throw out this problem yeah so I
think
basically people who who have lots of
money yeah they're the ones who can
afford 500 questions it's the unique Ali
dad program
dating after divorce yeah there you go
that's that could be a nice niche to go
into you thing is you've got all of
those choices you can make all of those
choices and adjustments as you go
further down the line okay they don't
have to be perfect like right now okay
damn man
I feel so I feel so inspired already and
I know we haven't done anything but just
like
seeing you break it down like I think in
my mind 2K a month was
like the the most obscure like there's
no way in [__] hell this is ever
gonna work
but
it's just 10 clients paying two and a
half k for a six-week transformational
program where I'm showing up every
single week to help help them through
the process and they're going to find
the love of their life fingers crossed
or at least someone to be in a long-term
relationship with yeah that makes it so
doable now there was something there was
something which popped up as well yeah
and I I don't know if anybody will have
caught this actually what maybe they'll
have to go and watch it back you might
have to watch it back but there was a
part of you which was like oh but all of
those doctors and nurses that are single
at the moment who are struggling to date
which I know is probably close to your
heart and like quite rightly so we can
help them too okay what we do is we we
build a business with um parameters so
it might be and I I call those clients
love clients okay and
um again I meet so many business owners
that are like oh I want to give back I
want to help as many people as I can
especially coaches they want to save the
world they want like eight billion
people like to work with all of them and
change their lives around you like it's
just not practical it's not going to
work but what we can do with the love
clients is we can build a business where
let's say for example if you accelerated
this and maybe you charge even more or
you get a few more clients in on that
one-to-one basis now you're working
full-time in this business well now
you've got five days to do as you
pleased with right yeah um how about if
you actually carved one of those days
out for the doctors and nurses it's your
you know that's your kind of like hero
product right and what if actually we
can't work with them all you know you'd
have to charge them a lower rate
potentially if they can't afford it and
I'm surprised they can afford to eat you
know at the moment the amount doctors
and nurses are paid but
um so maybe what you do is you introduce
a group program
you know a membership or something like
that where they get access to the IP
maybe maybe it's a self-paced learning
yeah with a weekly q a on a Friday just
for the doctors and nurses yep right and
they get a preferential rate for that
when they show their their doctoral
nurse badge
um and that's your way of giving back to
those love clients
I could even give it to I I could I
could even give it to them for free
you could see yeah
yeah 100 my my hesitation with that is
would they value it if it was free would
they do the work if it was free do they
need to have a little bit of something
yeah a little bit of skin in the game
yeah doctors are notorious about signing
up to free stuff and then not actually
yeah yeah so so it might be that I don't
know maybe they get it but a reduced
rate maybe yeah maybe that's the price
we started off one thing that I've seen
this other this other business do is
that you pay something upfront but if
you do the work you get a full refund
yeah and that would be sick like if I
could charge them like I don't know even
even like 500 credit for the whole six
months and they know they're going to
get the refund if they do the work yeah
that would really motivate them to do
the work and so many more doctors and
nurses would be in relationships then
yeah sick
but I can't build a business around that
because the economics don't work out as
we figured out yeah okay but but I can
have that as like my side hustle yeah
once once I've once I'm making my 20
okay full-time coaching program you
unique alidad program to you know
transformation and yeah side hustle
helping the doctors and nurses meet the
love of their life wow that sounds so
good
but okay right where do we go from here
what's the next step I'm I'm sold I'm
down to to make This brilliant excellent
so next step is um you just got to get
out there and start pitching so now it's
you know we've agreed the price points
two and a half K you've got to go and
find 10 people sit down and have a 30
minute conversation with them and then
pitch your offer
um I can guarantee that if you find 10
people who are pretty much the right
sort of client for this
um based on that one in five to one and
three conversion rate which I talked
about so yeah somewhere between two
three or four of those people are going
to say yes to this okay out of those
first ten and like if we're working on
just like worst case scenario one and
five are going to say yes so you've only
got to do five consultations a month
with prospective deities yeah
um to get that one client a month that
you need to make this work that feels
very doable yeah I'm uh I'm a pretty
good I'm I'm pretty sure I can come into
people that this is worthwhile I've also
got the whole clinical communication
skills going for me my only I'm just
like how how the hell am I going to find
five of these people each month where do
they hang out
where do single people hang out bars
yeah what are they searching for on
Google
are they in Facebook groups like this is
where you've got to start like marketing
101 okay that's that's what you're
asking me for basically
um yeah marketing 101 is four very
simple steps okay okay so first of all
once we figured out who our ideal client
is yep so if those are like you said you
kind of listed off a few that yeah the
Consultants the bankers the lawyers the
people working in finance in the city
that's it yep yep so there's a few
different audiences there the um Step
number two of marketing 101 is we then
ask the question whether they hang out
so probably they're looking through
scrolling through Facebook maybe on
Instagram probably looking at dating
sites and things like that
um we can start to look at
psychographics and demographics based on
those our ideal clients so demographics
is easy because that's like you know age
gender location those sorts of things
psychographics though which is where it
starts to get interesting with step two
is like what are their behaviors so what
magazines do they read what Facebook
groups are they in uh what pages who do
they subscribe to you know what podcasts
do they listen to all of those sorts of
things behaviors
that there's another tier below that
which is like um I call it the identity
layer so this is like
um and one of it's probably easier if I
talk about sort of the types of clients
I work with because this is where I sort
of learned about this um
um I've noticed that um a lot of my
clients have like a slight Edge to them
they're like um uh so for me for example
I like to do I like to go surfing and
cycling I love going down a hill I think
the fastest I've been on my pedal bike
is 52 and a half miles an hour down a
hill
um locally so it's pretty pretty fast
and scary uh I surf 12-foot waves so I I
have like this edgy sort of side to me
and it seems like I had that's my
identity I like cycling surfing and
cycling and I seem to attract clients
who are and have that similar sort of
edginess to them they're into their like
slight extreme sports or Ultra marathons
or they go out doing you know wild
camping on Dartmoor and stuff like that
their weekends you know on their own and
and whatnot so they've all got this
slight Edge so
um finding clients who share similar
values to you have similar sort of
identity to you actually makes the
process of finding clients that much
easier
oh okay interesting so you can identify
them where you know where they hang out
okay yeah as you said that identity
thing it reminds it made me kind of
realize that
I think my identity you know I was very
sort of bookish when I was in school and
University and still am and wasn't
really want to hang out at parties and
things which is why when we thought
about the bar thing I was like oh I
don't know I don't really go to bars but
I imagine there are a lot of people like
me who are kind of a little bit socially
awkward but who still really want to be
in a relationship and who could do with
a lot of help with their dating yeah
profiles and things like that because
those are the people who I was I was
like that back in the day and it took me
reading about relationships to really
diving diving into it and then applying
the insights to my own life yeah for me
to realize oh there's actually a method
here and it's not that hard and so if I
can find those kind of like nerds rather
than the jocks
like my ideal client is not someone who
was on the football team at school
there's someone who was maybe top 20 in
the year group at school and was then
the bottom set of PE that's that's the
person who I think yeah exactly yeah
that's the person but is anyone that
your friends come see for like
relationship advice yeah but all my
friends do you see all of my friends are
nerds yeah yeah so the so the identity
layer is actually like massively
important it's more important even than
the demographics and psychographics yeah
okay
so and that that gives you Clues because
there will be places online where
they'll hang out and you can start to
then Target your marketing at them so so
step one who's your ideal client step
number two where do they hang out step
number three we've got to go to them
okay and the reason we go to them is
because like people are busy it's 2023
we've all got busy hectic lives you know
especially post covered and all that
sort of thing it just seems like it's
non-stop go all the time so if we can
find creative ways to get in front of
our ideal client without them having to
extend any extra effort We Stand more
chance of being able to just start to
build rapport and build that
relationship with them
um so we need to put things in front of
them
um to to start to raise their awareness
of our our brand and what we're up to
and then step number four and this is
the bit that a lot of people especially
starting out don't realize you then have
to be tenacious you have to show up
regularly and often with the same
consistent message
because how many times have you probably
seen like ads pop up on as you're
scrolling or on telly or something like
that and you see the same ad seven times
11 times 20 times and then you just
think I'm gonna buy that thing and you
think you just did it on the spur at the
moment but it's actually because you saw
the ad like 20 times it's it's sowed the
seed of an ideal that brand becomes
familiar with you so for example like
the dating side of things and if you
know that people are um book smart
well you could set up a Facebook ad for
example which gives away your seven
unique seven step process not the whole
kit in caboodle but you could give away
all of the IP and the value if you
wanted to but run a Facebook ad give
away you know uh in exchange for their
name email address and telephone number
give away a Google doc which outlines
your seven step process
and if they're if they're that way
inclined they can follow those steps and
go and find the love of their life under
their own steam yeah so it's the reason
why I wrote the book is because I know
that there's some smart people out there
who'll read the book learn what they
need to do like what they need to get
from the book they'll go out there and
they'll just execute it yeah when
there's a small percentage of people who
are able to do that yeah but we also
know there's a bigger percentage of
people who get very excited about that
seven step process not quite have the
confidence to be able to do it
themselves or can't quite see themselves
doing it or whatever whatever is
stopping them from like getting started
with it
so who are they going to turn to to get
some help
this is going to be a banging Google doc
yeah yeah and it's going to have um it's
going to have a couple of case studies
in there of like happy you know success
stories of clients um clients couples
that have got together as a result of
the the work you've done with them
um maybe you've built a Facebook
community and it's got some you know
clients it's got some wins in there so
if people like you have your Friday wins
people put you know I went out on a date
last night it was absolutely amazing
hoping to go on a second date and that
we cut and paste that we pop that into
the Google Doc yeah you know so we're
building up a whole sort of um thing
around sort of social proof and it's a
Google like it doesn't need to be a
fancy website
you can build a website if you want to
but it could be for now we want to we
want to get something up like uh
bootstrap it we can make it better later
we're going to take a very quick break
from the podcast to introduce our
sponsor brilliant.org I've been using
brilliant for a few years now and it's a
fantastic online platform for courses in
maths and science and computer science
now one of my life philosophies is that
we should all Endeavor to be lifelong
Learners if we want because it's good
for the mind it's good for the body it's
good for our general happiness and
health and Brilliant is a perfect
resource from this because you can
really level up your own thinking in
terms of maths and science and computer
science without having to spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars on extra degrees
or extra courses now the courses are
brilliant are actually great because
they take what could be dry Topics in
math and science and computer science
and they turn them into really
interesting interactive and enjoyable
kind of experiences where you learn a
little bit and then you apply it in
practice and then you learn a bit more
and then you put it into practice and
it's almost like the system that we used
to use in our tutorials back when I was
at University of Cambridge where you
would learn a little thing and then
you'd be paired with a world-class
expert in the thing and then be asking
you questions and you'd be kind of
figuring it out together rather than
being spoon fed information like we're
normally taught in school each lesson on
brilliant is broken up into 15-minute
bite-sized chunks and so wherever you
are in your day you can find a little
bit of time you can go on the app and
you can level up your brain rather than
scrolling social media or whatever the
other default activity might be and it's
pretty cool as well because they're
constantly updating the library of
courses for example they've recently
released a course introduction to
algebra and this is like a visual
representation of algebraic thinking now
I thought I understood algebra because I
did maths in school but actually the way
that brilliant explains it with kind of
the stories and the puzzles and the
interactive exercises you go along has
really given me a new understanding of
algebra that I just didn't have before
and that maybe you would need to do like
a math degree to actually get that grasp
of what algebra actually is and why it's
so important so if any of that sounds up
you're straight and you'd like to level
up your thinking and your knowledge in
maths or science or computer science
then head over to brilliant.org forward
slash deep dive and the first 200 people
to click that link which will be in the
show notes and in the video description
as well we'll get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you so
much brilliant for sponsoring this
episode and let's get right back to the
podcast the way that I've approached
everything at school and University it's
like trying to aim for Perfection
because when you hand in the assignment
you can't just improve it later you have
to work on it so hard and and then but
you have to remember though Ali like
when you're in medicine lives depend on
it it has to be perfect yeah right and
there's not many things that have that
level of Jeopardy in them like what you
work through with with medicine and when
it comes to business like you know I
think everybody thinks that it's the
equivalent of somehow walking across the
plains of Africa and you you know a bit
different when you've got to walk 10
miles to the river to get and there's
hippos and lions and things actual
things that can eat you whereas like in
business you can make mistakes you call
them failures if you want to but you can
use them as opportunities to learn and
there's only two things that can
possibly go wrong you lose a bit of
money or you lose a bit of face it's a
little bit stupid or you back to where
you started again before yeah and you go
again you come up with another idea
another Google doc another Facebook ad
another whatever
and the thing is like inside we get we
think that everybody's watching us yeah
I'm thinking all my friends all the
nurses at work all of my junior doctor
colleagues are going to be like huh what
a [__] this early guy thinking he can
give relationship advice he doesn't even
have a qualification it sounds to me
like they're not true friends
your true friends will be like
supportive my true friends wouldn't care
they'd be like sick yeah exactly I'm
thinking about the colleagues at work
yeah well screw them screw them let them
do you know do them yeah and this is
about building success for you okay okay
so marketing 101
figure out the target audience yep where
do they hang out yep
go to them and what was the last one be
tenacious you show up regularly and
often with the same consistent message
do I have to do this via Facebook ads or
like how no no what are the other you
could go um so it could be
um
uh there's probably like uh dating
meetups for example where single people
go yeah on like you know I know you said
you don't necessarily like the whole
idea of going to Bar could be a bit
cringy but there's there's I've been
single for a very long time actually no
but I'm kind of making a few assumptions
okay no but okay but if I think about it
like my okay my my ideal target market
is basically a professional who is a
nerd who is making decent amounts of
money probably earning at least I'd say
50k a year
that is someone working in Okay cool so
things that I could do to get at that
Target Market I could run a Facebook ad
or I mean I don't know anything about
that but I'm assuming you can Target it
at particular occupations LinkedIn yeah
links to these people are on LinkedIn
yeah there you go loads them on LinkedIn
see and also like I think one of my
friends works at McKinsey and I know
they put on all these like afternoon
talks and [__] at lunchtime I could say
to the friend hey I'll do a totally free
workshop on helping management
Consultants with dating yeah and I could
oh they love a good PowerPoint I could
turn it I could put my seven part method
into a good PowerPoint there you go and
if I can get my foot in the door with
McKinsey those people at that lunchtime
talk will be perfectly primed to be
young people with loads of money with
shitty dating lives and they could
benefit from my model from my model yeah
there you go oh okay now that you didn't
even need me to give you the blueprint
you came up with all of that yourself
mate okay
and then I've got another friend who
works at Bain another friend at BCG
another friend of Deloitte another
friend at PWC another friend of Goldman
Sachs even if Mackenzie say no I'm sure
I could
say to all these mates working in all
these different companies like actually
and actually
if I think about it all my friends
working at any kind of Finance or Tech
thing in any kind of job in London all
of their workplaces with the exception
of the NHS do lunchtime teaching type
talks yeah so I could just copy paste
message to all of them be like hey I'm
doing this thing totally free Workshop
what do you think is going to happen as
well so the the first few clients you
get in
their success stories they follow your
methodology they meet somebody and then
somebody says oh my God Ali you're so
happy
like yeah what happened how did you meet
them yeah like what are they going to
say they're going to refer me yeah yeah
and even offer them affiliate
commissions
wow okay this suddenly seems doable okay
fine
so I know this now I know I could run a
Facebook ad even though I mean okay so
let's say it's not
let's say I don't have access to these
kind of networks
um and let's say I don't have any
friends working in the sort of places
where I could attract my target audience
how would for example a Facebook or
LinkedIn ad help with something like
this
like I've seen ads on Facebook LinkedIn
and stuff but I have no idea how they
how they work yeah so but it accelerates
the process I mean if you think about it
like I mean people are saying that
people are sort of mass migration away
from Facebook and into Tick Tock and
other things like that but right now
like there's still have many billion
four billion people still registered on
Facebook so you only need 10 people
surely there's 10 people out there you
know who fit the profile that you've
kind of laid out so it's kind of more to
amplify I like to think that your first
10 clients probably are already in your
network you probably already know them
all of those people you just listed off
um so it might be that that works and
then uh let's say for example if it's so
popular and you're getting loads of
inquiries you might then want to turn
this into a group coaching program not a
one-to-one coaching program
right so now rather than helping
template tape 10 people a year you've
got so much demand actually we want to
help 50 or 100 or 200 people could do we
can Workshop seminars like exactly just
rent a hotel conference room in London
and like totally put on a workshop if I
if I had if only people would show up
yeah so if you're once like I always
recommend like coaches start one-to-one
because that's where you sharpen your
swords you you learn you see whether
your methodology works or not you
improve it if there are bits which don't
work
um but once you've got a proven
methodology quite often then you can
transfer it across into into a group
setting there'll be a version of it that
you can make work
um but the challenges a lot of people
don't have demand so they don't have the
audit the size of audience to be able to
fill it at scale so that's where you
could use
um ads then to amplify your message
everything is Downstream of lead
generation yeah that's what I heard in a
Dan Priestly interview on a podcast one
time yeah New Generation that's what
we're talking about right basically lead
generation we're trying to generate
leads by identifying a Target Avatar
figuring out where they are going to
them and doing it repeating yeah easy
yep why do so many people struggle with
this because when you laid out like that
well I mean there's technology involved
isn't there so that there's
um
like ads ads is a science in its own
right and Facebook changed the rules
like every five minutes as well so yeah
um but I guess you know there's
technology involved in every job like I
learned how to
you know do an arterial blood gas which
involves like stabbing someone and
somebody in the arm I'm sure I can learn
how to set up a Facebook ad yeah exactly
I'm not going to be but you're a smart
guy Ali there's people who are like
technologically averse
um now the way I look at that is is that
true or are they using that as a bit of
an excuse a crutch to lean on and say oh
I'm not very good at this like they fall
back on it a little bit one of the most
common things I hear in businesses are
not very good with numbers right and
that really angers me I nearly swore
then really angers me right the reason
for that is because everything about
business involves numbers okay profit
and loss turnover gross profit net
profit overheads and expenses all
numbers conversion rates number of leads
which you need number of website
visitors number of likes comments and
shares you get on your Facebook post the
number of people who like your Facebook
page all they're all numbers you look at
everything within business
it all revolves around numbers in some
way shape or form so there's I don't
believe business owners can sit there
and say I'm not very good with numbers
however
a slight caveat that said
you only have to understand enough about
numbers to then be able to delegate
responsibility to somebody else
because otherwise again I see a lot of
people who hand off like oh I'm not very
I don't understand tax so I'll give it
to an accountant and then they wonder
why they get a surprise at the end of
the year because the accountant says
well you've got to pay X number of
thousands of pounds of tax oh my God I
wasn't expecting that
um well no it's because you kind of just
delegated responsibility to somebody
else you didn't delegate responsibly you
delegated responsibility and you don't
therefore that's always going to come
back as a shock when you've got to pay
tax the end of the year so what you want
to do is you want to understand numbers
enough so that when you make 10K in a
month you know that and this is where
you get into like profit first territory
which are you familiar with Mike
mcculloughitz's book profit first
so he talks about
um than I am but not the the
relationship the coach version of me
so in it he basically talks about like
because
uh having like five different bank
accounts effectively and like
Starling and Monza so online banking
apps now have made this so much easier
because I have these little things
called spacers so you have one bank
account but you siphon off little bits
of money
but he basically says well you set the
sides in the UK your your vat your
corporation tax if you've got employees
paye National Insurance contributions
uh you have a little I can call it the
fun pop so I that normally for me that's
like buying camera gear and then the
other one is the rainy day fund so you
have a savings Kitty for if we had no
money for six months could could would
the business still work basically
function
and then and then your main account is
then just like a float so just
day-to-day expenses money coming in and
out and things like that and the idea is
so that if 10K comes in well 2K goes to
that 1K goes to you know corporation tax
1K gas National Insurance concert you
know so you divvy it up the moment the
money comes in so by the end of the year
when you do your returns
you've got the money saved up to pay all
of your taxes up front hopefully you've
got a bit of extra money because you've
put some in your fun part and in your
rainy day fund so you could draw some of
that down if you want you know and spend
that on just fun stuff or reinvest it
into the business and things like that
and like again the amount of times I
hear business owners say I've got a cash
flow problem
I'm sorry I'm a total geek when it comes
to numbers you're going to hear me so
cash flow they see it's like the money
just basically flowing in and out of the
business right okay so having a cash
flow problem is that just a euphemism
for I'm Brooke uh kind of basically
because it's not a cash flow problem
because if money flows in it flows
straight back out again so there's no
cash flow problem there they've got two
problems though the actual real problems
are making more money yep so this is
where we talk have the pricing
conversation and second to that is then
keeping that money yeah right because
what I typically tend to see is the um
uh I don't know you're going to explain
this to podcast listeners hopefully this
will work for the video but people as
their turnover starts to increase like
that which is like the dream isn't it
straight line upwards
um the overheads start to track up with
it because we're like right we've got
money to reinvest whether that's in
staff or
um Machinery kit whatever it might be
what you know marketing starts to track
up now we have the bad month and now our
expenses are up here and our revenues
down here so we're now in this position
of loss and that's where the fear really
kicks in for a lot of people now
normally you can see it because it
doesn't just all of a sudden go like
that it starts to sort of tail off
so I'm I'm a big fan of like
bootstrapping businesses especially
because Japan keep your expenses as low
as you possibly can do be really
conscientious about where where and who
you're spending your money with
um you know especially on things like
marketing there's like a thousand and
one shiny marketing things you could
could spend your money on we talked
about some of them websites marketing
branding you know lead generation you'll
you know you'll get sold those like
every day of the week by lots of
different people but
um and
people invest so much money in those
sorts of things on the hope that they
will work so they don't really tend to
do their due diligence somebody will say
I'll do this and you'll get 10 to 15
leads a week and all that sort of stuff
invariably from my experience those two
those you know it sounds too good to be
true invariably it is but they do tend
to cost quite a lot of money
so be very you know it's just a cautious
cautionary tale about just be careful
about letting your expenses track up too
much
another common mistake in business as
well is
um
uh and again it's it's a it's a an arc
I've got with marketing is that
um people believe the goal in business
is to get as many clients as they
possibly can do for their business
right
do you do you agree with that or do you
think there's an alternative goal I
think based on the capacity pricing
conversation that we had
my goal is not actually to get 100
clients because I don't think I can
service 100 clients because I just don't
physically have the time I'd rather get
10 clients who pay me
more yeah then have 100 clients who pay
me less so you've got 10 clients to pay
you more what does that mean for the
business that means I have more time to
give to them yep so better better
quality results yeah yeah it means I'm
less stressed because I only have 10
people to deal with rather than 50. and
it means that through the revenue
generated through those 10 people I can
then do my pro bono service to my
doctors and nurses friends
for free so it's profit to reinvest back
into the business yeah so imagine now
like imagine if you went from 10 clients
to 100 clients what have you got to do
you've got to spend loads of money on
marketing so all of a sudden the
Investments like go up tenfold and I'd
probably have to hire people as well to
deal with 100 clients because it
wouldn't just be able to be me yeah so
collecting clients like yeah I've got no
problem you obviously have to do some
form of marketing but you have to be
Savvy about it
um you know out of I liken it to um I
call it it's the marketing mix basically
you find
two three or four things which work
really really well for your business
marketing wise and then you rinse and
repeat those and they might have a
half-life they may only last for so long
especially if they involve technology
um probably wouldn't surprise you I've
used Facebook ads for my business in the
past and
um uh I lost nine grand as a result of a
mistake I made with running Facebook ads
okay
um and the reason for that is because I
um it was it was working to a certain
point and I but I I did made a kind of
like Cardinal error
um in your audiences you'll have people
who are just like ready to buy
already in in your circle of influence
okay okay so we we reached a point
whereby we all of those people who are
in our Circle my circle of influence
who'd they bought from us yeah and then
all of a sudden our conversions dropped
off a cliff so we weren't signing up as
many clients yep my ads are still
running and I'm spending three grand a
month yeah and it took me three months
to figure out what had gone wrong with
the audience again numbers I I'd try to
analyze the numbers but I couldn't
figure out what the problem was with it
and eventually I figured it out but in
the meantime I've spent three months
spending three grand so it's a costly
mistake right so we we kind of gotten
this when you said that you don't like
it when people say I'm not good with
numbers yeah
like half the people I know even the
doctors would say that they're not good
with numbers so does that mean worrying
well exactly yeah so does that mean that
people who are not good with numbers
can't run a business not not necessarily
um in many many respects like if you're
numerically dyslexic for example then
like I see the books over your shoulder
there it's an unfair Advantage because
it it forces you to be creative in other
ways so you make up for it in other
aspects of the business
it might be that you've got to find the
support of somebody who does get numbers
within the business so have have a
mentor or a coach or an accountant some
kind of an advisor who can help you out
in that respect and just say oh you're
overspending a bit here or you could be
making a bit more profit yeah I think if
I'm if I'm being honest most people I
know who say they're not good enough
with numbers they're not actually
numerically dyslexia like one in 30 of
them if I think of people that I know
they managed to do drug dosing
completely fine they managed to do like
kind of weight and Drug calculations
it's but maybe because they didn't do a
level maths or a level further math they
think oh I'm not good I'm not I'm not
good with numbers and it's like a story
that they've just told themselves
repeatedly to the point that the thought
of
dealing with tax or hearing number
hearing fancy words like operating
profit and you know margin and all that
[__] give the real kind of emotional
like sense of overwhelm yeah I think
it's a sense of stepping outside the
comfort zone rather than really being a
case of being numerically dyslexic
the motivators though to understand like
just
profit the goal in business is to make
money by the way yeah like have a
profitable sustainable business
um and that is ultimately the thing that
everybody wants yeah if you said to
those people that you could be making 3K
months doing your business will that
prompt you to learn about the numbers
they'd be like well yes obviously
but it's yeah I think I think it's one
of those like excuses just like I'm not
good with technology yeah but like like
come on let's be fair like tax is boring
I'm not gonna lie sorry if there's any
accounts like listening to this but it
is dull but but again just you don't
need to understand tax and things like
that leave that to an accountant but as
long as you understand turnover and net
profit just those two numbers yeah how
much money is coming in and how much you
have left yeah yeah then that's a good
start right so at this point in our
relationship coaching practice
by the way do I need a name do I need a
business card do I need a website like
what's the deal with all this stuff not
yet those can all come later but to
launch business you just need to get out
there and start talking to people should
I register the business should I make a
business bank account should I deal with
no none of that so okay um and the
reason for that is so
um uh now I have to know my numbers here
to be able to give advice but so take in
the UK for example you can actually
there's a certain amount of money which
you can earn on a reg on an annual basis
as a side hustle without having to
register it as a business or something
like that so you could for example just
go out and
your first client actually charged them
900 pounds and stay within that
threshold just to try it out just to see
whether it works for example um
uh you can go self-employed to start off
with and then obviously as part of a you
just have to do a tax return at the end
of the financial year declare any income
pay the tax keep it nice and simple you
don't need a business bank account or a
limited company or anything like that
you know some sometimes when you're
starting out simple is better
um
that said it's I think sometimes it's
good to offer the the other flip side to
it as well so for example when I shifted
from my agency
um uh practice which I was running into
the coaching practice
I there were certain things that I
wanted to set out intentionally to do
the right way do things the right way
with so for example
um I knew that I wanted to earn 100K in
my coaching practice I set that as like
my big hairy audacious goal from year
one like that's what I wanted to achieve
and so 100K business has to be that
registered so from day one I went
limited I went vat registered and I set
out with that intention and part of that
was like just future pacing myself yeah
because that's the business I wanted to
be right
um so you can have the more
laissez-faire approach uh might be and
people vary so if you're if you're
slightly risk-averse you're not sure
whether this has got legs or not yeah
let's just dip our toe in and try it on
for size and see whether see whether the
shirt fits or if you're like no I'm
going to make this a thing I'm going for
it I'm gonna do it properly let's set up
a limited company go about Richard nice
go for it okay I've just asked child GPT
give me name ideas for a relationship
coaching business where I do six month
Transformations for people to help them
find a life partner and I've got a bunch
of names I like uh option number nine is
connection Catalyst nice and I've just
searched for that on Google and there
there is in fact a connection Catalyst
limited but it was dissolved in 2018 so
that's probably good cool connection
Catalyst that's the name of the name of
this boom okay job done so the stuff
that we've gone through so far kind of
figuring out the business model
identifying the talking blah blah blah
blah would that happen in like one
coaching session with you or like what
what's the process for like uh an
ordinary person starting completely from
scratch and how how long does it take to
get them to a idea that they then take
action on yeah I mean it's like anything
some sometimes people get it in one
session and away they go sometimes
people everybody operates at different
speeds so sometimes it might be a three
or a six or a 12 month Journey which
they've got to go through and especially
like one of the things we were talking
about was running running this as a side
hustle yeah so if you've got a full-time
job and you have less resources
available at your time obviously it's
going to take a bit little bit longer
potentially to achieve those goals but
um I I did work with one client
um who uh so they joined Fearless on the
Tuesday we did a coaching call on the
Wednesday they had two sales calls on
the Thursday and Friday yeah
um and they doubled their their
investment that they paid me in that so
in four days they'd made double the
money back that they'd invested with me
so it can happen super fast
on the flip side of that I worked with a
communications consultant and she was
very she was very honest up front she
was like I've got some money to save I'm
not desperate for clients I've got one
specific client I want to work with
um so she was in the educational space
uh she wanted to work with ucas and
um that that was like her dream client
and so she did some other bits on the
side as and when they came in but it was
effortless organic
um and it took a year but eventually she
closed 180 Grand contract so
um in her words it was worth the wait
yeah you know and that was when she'd
been doing sort of previously sort of
day rate at like 200 pounds 250 pounds a
day to then get 180 Grand contract it
was life-changing you know that's the
Catalyst for her
um Community you know her Communications
consultancy then to go on and get bigger
and better clients off the back of that
nice
so okay question
let's say we're taking the conversation
towards the relationship thingy
um we went down this route of like
what's the what's the transformation you
can get them in what amount of time yeah
and I just kind of went with that
because you pushed me in kind of in that
direction but now I think about it what
is wrong with discharging hourly
I mean I I did a video about this that I
I'd actually truly believe that irony
rate charging is unethical right and the
reasons for this is so imagine if you
did want to go and get a website done
for example uh well maybe maybe you're
you're doing a beauty parade and there's
three web designers okay so web designer
number one comes along alley and he says
to you right I can build your website
I'll do everything you want to do
um it's going to take me 10 hours
um uh and I'll charge you 100 pounds an
hour for it so about a thousand pounds
and you think okay cool uh so he goes
away what he forgot to tell you though
was he's not been doing it for very long
uh he's not particularly good at it uh
because he's not charging enough he's
taken on too many clients so he comes
back eventually about five months later
um with a bit of a hack together sort of
website it doesn't have the blog or the
shopping cart on there that he promised
you and what do you say
where's my blogger my shopping cart yeah
and he and can you add them on and he
says well yeah I can add them on but
it's going to cost you another five
hours
and you're like well okay but I thought
you told it me is going to take 10 and
and so he reluctantly agrees he says
okay well I'll just build it now you're
annoyed that he's this you know at one
end of the spectrum as a customer uh
he's now a bit like you know reticent
because like he's not getting paid what
he thinks he's worth because now he's
doing work for free effectively yeah
um most people are like ethically
morally upstanding human beings and they
wouldn't just tag on the extra money but
the mere fact that you could tells me
that hourly rate charging is a broken
business model okay so there's our first
clue that hourly rates don't work right
web designer number two comes along
right so he says to you he's more
experienced he says ali uh could build
your website in in 30 days
um it'll have everything which you want
on it
um and
um I'm gonna charge you 100 pounds an
hour for it
um but because I'm better than the other
guy I can do it faster so it'll take me
five hours to do it
I'm thinking well you're getting a good
deal as the customer but surely the guy
who can do it better and faster and
deliver better results why does he get
paid less than the guy who's less
experienced and is still learning and
doing making a bit of a hash of it
so again tells you that there's nothing
unethical going on there but it tells
you that Ali rates is a broken business
model yeah the incentives are wrong here
yeah so now we get web designer number
three comes along absolute like website
ninja he says Ali I'm gonna build you
the website in seven days have a
shopping cart uh it'll have the blog on
there that you wanted to be able to edit
all the content yourself we'll get it
connected up to Google Store so your
products will be listed in there within
about 14 days
um and we'll be selling your products
and uh by the way if we can't get you a
10x Roi on the investment you make with
us within the first 12 months we'll give
you your money back for that plus we'll
also pay you a thousand pounds of
wasting your time which you can spend on
the other two people who are kind of
playing at it
yeah that's someone I'd be like wow this
is like some some good energy cool ask
me how much how much is it 10K 10K yeah
let's go cool so but it's 10 times the
price of the other two if you think
about it yet because he's got a clear
idea about he's got he's got his process
processes down it's all systemized he
knows that he only works with you know
YouTube influencers for example so he he
only has one type of client service he
knows that he could I say he could be
she as well
um that they can deliver remarkable
results and they can do it predictably
um and therefore they can put that
guarantee in there they're going to
deliver you those results damn so the
value proposition is that much stronger
hourly rates don't exist in that
transaction even if it only takes that
person an hour to build it yeah nice so
if I would start starting a relationship
coaching business I shouldn't think
hourly pricing is my definitely go too
definitely not um it's got to be based
on the results which you deliver for
clients pure and simple is there any
business that is good to do hourly
pricing on like
could I not just do some one-on-one
coach Consulting equals and oh I don't
have to think too hard about it they can
just book via calendly link or something
but listen to the do you notice the
language you used in that oh I could
just do this it kind of feels a bit like
you're just playing at it I'm just
halfing it yeah yeah so are you serving
the client when you're running your
business like that
no I am essentially serving myself
because I don't want to work too hard
yeah exactly
hmm okay you kind of made it about you
and in this instance like well in any
instance the client is the most
important person in the relationship so
it's the same reason why people get
really hung up with sales like sales
calls people have so much fear around
selling yeah
um and they get onto sales calls the
next thing you know their palms are
going sweaty their heart starts racing
it gets to that really pointy end of the
conversation where the person says how
much and then they kind of retreat like
Gollum and they're like well right you
kind of
at that point what have they done or
they've made everything entirely about
them they're no longer serving the
client
like how can you operate
um with a client's best interests at
heart
when you're only thinking about yourself
[Music]
um
nice it's the same reason why
um people and like when they're selling
they have this massive fear of no
fear of rejection
they I mean it's a human instinct we
we're we're heard animals at the end of
the day pack animals we like to be
accepted so if we hear the word no we
take it as a massive rejection right but
what what are they actually saying no to
they're saying no to the offer yeah say
no to the offer which is attached to is
it attached to the person of the
business attach the business attach the
business yeah right
and this is where you get into like just
a really simple model of how to
um
when things aren't going to plan in your
business normally it's because things
aren't going to plan with you hmm that's
the Royal you not just you Ali but the
Royal you so imagine we've got Ali over
here and we've got Ali's business over
here if Ali's value systems are all over
the place this relationship is up or
down he's just having a bad day and he
walks into the office and those two
things are attached yep what's going on
yeah the business is having a wobble as
well
but
what the business needs is
um solid foundations
so all the things which you've been
through with your coaches and mentors
the growth Journey been the new business
it's all about building solid
foundations
um having a team in who understand what
their roles and responsibilities are
systems and processes like Sops standard
pricing procedures all of that sort of
stuff
um
um and the key thing is as well that
um your businesses
um oxygen is money it needs a good
income to provide security that's like
the the walls if you like and the roof
going on the top to protect it
um and
um what it needs is so you can have all
of your wobbles as a business only going
going on over here but when you do start
to
for work for business like you're a rock
for your business and then you switch
off your iPad or your laptop or whatever
at the end of the day at five o'clock
and then you can carry on having your
wobbles over here like the business so
when somebody says no they just don't
get the value that your business offers
it's it's not personal yeah it's not an
insult it's not anything it's the
business which I have a problem with
I love it okay
so I've Got My Business Connection
Catalyst and I've managed to land one
free workshop at like a consulting firm
of of some description and because I
listened to the Daniel Priestley
interview on Oliver's deep Life podcast
I chose not to charge for that Workshop
so because I wanted to get in my foot in
the doors because everything is
Downstream of lead generation and I've
got like 15 people in a room they've
showed up they've their arms are folded
they're a bit skeptical they're like you
know what is this really connection
Catalyst BS and because I know my [__] I
prepared my talk I've prepared my
PowerPoint on my slides I take them
through the seven part method I may have
read Russell Broad and Bronson's book
expert Secrets which talked about how
exactly how to do this
and then what do I do at the end of it
when it comes to like telling people
about my thing
uh well first mistake is you wait until
the end of your presentation to tell
them about what you your next the next
step is okay interesting so like
do you not get the ick whenever we've
all sat in these presentations right
workshops conferences where
the speakers like building up to this
Crescendo this offer yeah and and they
get to the end of it and then they start
talking about their value ladder oh we
we normally sell it for this but we're
gonna today it's we're gonna knock down
the price we're gonna sell and we all
get that we don't like that bit right so
put the offer at the start of the
presentation okay it's a bit like um
because then they've got something that
they can measure the value against okay
so at the start of the presentation
you're going to do your hey that's great
thank you so much all for showing up
today massively appreciate it we're
gonna make this a really fun and
interactive Workshop I've got seven
really cool steps which I'm gonna um
take you through and by the end of it
you'll know everything you need to go to
get your dream partner but just before
we go into that I just want to tell you
a little bit more about me and what I do
so then we pivot into the pitch where
you can tell people about
your credibility your Authority like why
you all of those sorts of things and
it's okay at that point say actually we
have a coaching program which takes
people on this journey so if you want if
you go through the seven steps
you can take it pla you know away you
know execute it if you think you can but
if you feel you want a bit of help like
get in touch with us
but one of the things I'm interested to
learn about is how ready you all are in
terms of like getting yourself out there
in the dating game so
um we've created a very short 15
question questionnaire I think you know
where I might be going with this uh
um uh on score app
here's the QR code scan the QR code and
just quickly take the quiz yeah and then
you sit back two or three minutes
everybody scans it they go through yeah
people love taking quizzes yeah so and
what it tells them is you could you
could make it about well what type of
data am I so like a profile type quiz
um uh it could be a
um which area of the dating game do you
feel is the worst that you might need to
work on you know or where do you feel
you could get the best results you know
if you did X Y and Z so you can give
them some kind of a specific outcome for
it now we've got the you've got the
leads which is great name email address
telephone number hopefully and a bit of
data about them through your score app
and
um all of that icky sales bits kind of
done now we can just park that and we
can just go and deliver the value man
that's good
that is good
I'm going to start doing that at start
at the start of my Keynotes and stuff
because people love a quiz it's so much
nicer to have at the start than at the
end yeah it's like a little Icebreaker
yeah and they get a bit of information
we get the salesy thing just out the way
and done and everybody can relax yeah do
you think you're gonna get better or
worse results after that
really better yeah yeah absolutely it's
more chill yeah
that's way more chill
yeah and then like them doing the quiz
as well like like the thing with a lot
of these quizzes is that it makes you
realize all the holes in your knowledge
this is what like one of the things in
learning design as well you give them
you give the class a quiz up front
before you teach them the stuff so they
see how bad they are and they're like oh
crap okay I don't know this I'm
therefore gonna pay attention whereas if
they don't know what they don't know
yeah it's it's less powerful well and
what's interesting as well is like if
you do it at the start and nobody really
knows what to expect you whatever you
kind of throw at them they're more
inclined to do it yeah because
um
I I and I can't remember who it was but
um getting people to take action so
um I think it was
um Simon sinek talks about the the laws
of diffusion about
um how uh so you have like the early
adopters and then you know as people
like as you implement change
um at what point do people kind of um
adopt that change and then start to kind
of get engaged with it and then you get
the laggards of people who just like
they just won't do anything that you
throw at them at all
um it's a similar sort of process when
you're doing
um sort of presentations and things like
that as well
um where am I going with this so
um and what kind of backs us up there's
a another great internet marketer a guy
called Frank Kern who's like brilliant
in like the copywriting sort of um space
and internet marketing space and he did
a talk in front of several thousand
people and he said I'm gonna
um I'm gonna give you the secret so that
you can all be millionaires but you need
to follow these very simple steps
and um he listed off the the steps which
was basically go and buy this book make
sure you follow the steps in the book uh
read the book ten times and follow all
the steps and then you will get all the
riches that you want the book was called
the richest man in Babylon oh no and as
he's kind of telling like walking people
through these steps the camera panned
around to the audience and he's like
right I want you to go to Amazon or
Barnes Noble I want you to
um search for this book so get your
phones out and search for this book I
want you to buy the book like now
and it pans to the audience and there's
like several thousand people there and
you could count the number of people who
had their phones out buying this book on
like your hands and your toes
it says 20 people out of thousands of
people
who are about to be delivered the secret
to my book and yet they can't even find
the energy to take the first step to buy
the book yeah
let alone then actually follow the steps
in it and execute it yeah it's probably
like one person out of that entire
audience who did it so this is like the
um I don't know what you'd call it the
resistance you're up against
not not just um when you're trying to
sell something in marketing there's this
natural sort of resistance which you're
fighting against there's a twitch
streamer called uh Ludwig who's also a
YouTuber who's absolutely huge um and he
has a YouTube video which is something
like
how to be a successful streamer in like
10 steps and it's like a sort of
hour-long video and he's like starts off
by being like okay I'm going to teach
you the 10 step process of how to be a
successful streamer why should you
listen to me well because I've blown up
and I've done this and I've done this
and I've done this so you really should
listen to me and I'm going to tell you
the steps let's go for it step number
one pause this video right now and just
answer these three questions what's your
goal how much time are you willing to
put in blah blah and then he's like no
I'm serious I know you know I'm sure you
guys are going to keep watching but like
genuinely pause the video right now I've
seriously pause the video and write down
these things he says that like five or
ten times and so I you know I was like
okay you know what I'm gonna pause the
video I wrote down those things and then
and then I press play and he's like
right I estimate less than 10 of you
actually stop actually pause the video
if that's you then quit right now
because there's no way you're ever going
to make in the streaming world the
streaming World requires so much Bliss
this this and this I am the biggest
streamer in the world and the fact you
have literally not followed me to saying
to you 10 times pause the [__] video
and write the and and then write these
three things down means there's just no
way in hell you're gonna make it so
switch this video off right now and just
and the comments in the video are like
oh my God he called me out he called me
out he called me out so much and I felt
good because I was like I actually
paused the video and take action but I
could I could have imagined the time in
my life where I was like oh you know
it's fine it's not gonna work anyway but
yeah I was like this guy knows his stuff
if I follow the steps of a guy who's
done the thing then it's like it's
obviously going to get results it's
natural selection basically that's
what's going on in that in that moment
and then people are sat there at home
and words why him why not me and it's
like well you didn't do something simple
didn't take the simple first step to
start to move towards your goals you
made up any excuse or put up any brick
wall for yourself that you can possibly
find to not make it work
I think there's oh there's almost a
natural
a natural a kind of defense mechanism
that people have when it comes to
I think I think especially in the UK I
feel like Americans have less of this
defense at least from what I've seen at
conferences any sort of a natural
defense to anything that seems even
remotely like oh this person's trying to
tell me what to do or they're trying to
promise something that's too big and
this sort of natural or this skepticism
that we have towards
following the advice of someone who's
been there and done that and we don't
have that skepticism when it comes to a
tennis lesson or a guitar teacher but we
sales coach or marketing coach or a
business coach or anything remotely in
the make money realm why any any
thoughts on that
um I think it's down to just um what are
preconceived ideas are about that thing
like you kind of know a little bit
about like if you're going to show up to
a tennis lesson you know that you're
probably gonna have to run about a bit
and swing your Racket and hit a few
balls right so that you've kind of got a
preconceived idea about it I think to a
lot of people there is a certain element
of mystery around what business is yeah
what it means and
I I always say to people like
um you you can do the website and the
The Branding and the domain names and
the all of all of the things like the
goal setting the business planning all
that sort of stuff but ninety percent of
everything you need to learn about
business you will get from just getting
out there and selling something and it
doesn't matter whether it's 20 pounds to
mow somebody's lawn if it's a uh you
know a six month transformational dating
program
um it doesn't matter what it is get out
there and sell something for some money
and see how you feel about it afterwards
it's as simple as that you'll learn 90
of everything you need to know because
within having to do that you had to
Market because you had to make somebody
aware
that you had a program to sell or that
you had a lawnmower to push around
somebody's Garden or whatever it might
be yeah
um you had to sell something because you
had to have that awkward conversation
okay yeah I'm interested in you mowing
my lawn about how much you're gonna cost
well I'll do it for 20 quid well gosh
well my my Gardener charges 15 pounds
now why are you so much better so you in
that sales process you learn something
about yourself and about your processes
and your business and all those sorts of
things uh then you move into you know
onboarding client onboarding what you
know giving somebody the next steps you
know what's their first session what
does that look like
um uh what time am I going to show up
with my lawnmower
um then it moves into client fulfillment
you know actually doing the work
um uh at the end of it that the doing
the work is tricky because if unless
you're getting feedback throughout it if
somebody's watching over you whilst they
mow the lawn and they have a go at you
because your stripes aren't quite right
on the lawn or whatever or maybe in the
coaching program somebody sat there a
bit confused and saying well I don't
think that's going to work for me
because I don't want to use that app for
my dating because
um for whatever reason
um so you might get some feedback within
the Fulfillment but then at the end of
it you can then see what does a client
pay you and are they happy
or do they not pay you are they unhappy
and leave negative reviews but within
that what can I learn from it
yeah
step-by-step process yeah basically but
along the way
for some reason in people's head there's
peril
or what if I put my marketing out there
and it doesn't work what if I sell some
try and sell something and they say no
what if I
try and onboard the client and then they
Backtrack on the agreement what if I try
and start doing the thing and find that
I'm not very good at it uh what if I
when I've done it and I'm not very good
at it I get a negative review so this
peril you know think about Harry Potter
and the journeys that he goes through
those Adventures there's parallel along
the way in there but again it comes back
to what's the two things that could go
wrong in business you look a bit stupid
or you end up losing a bit of money and
actually neither of them are that bad in
the grand scheme of things
love it yeah I think one of the things
that really helped simplify the whole
business stuff for me is just
appreciating that there are only a
finite number of actual business models
that you could follow
um
there's like the service based business
model where you are selling a service
and you do something and someone finds
the thing valuable or you help them with
something they find anything valuable
and they pay you for it cool or you make
some kind of product
whether it's a physical product or a
like online product or whatever the
thing is and someone finds a thing they
pay you for the thing and that's all
well and good and then maybe on the side
you have like a Content business model
which is like you make the content
the platforms pay you for it and then
you sell something either a good or a
service to someone further down the line
and essentially outside those three
then you start getting into complicated
territory like for example you know day
trading and sort of trying to use money
to make money type stuff but and and it
starts to get complicated yeah and I
think when most people think of oh I
want to make money on the internet I
want to start a business they don't
think oh I'll just sell a service or
sell a product they think oh my God
there's all these different options out
there there's like the day trading the
paid surveys that this that that start a
YouTube channel become a tick tocker I
guess I could I don't know start a web
design agency it feels like one option
out of many but whenever I speak to
actual entrepreneurs it's like they've
built a service business or they've
built a product business and that's kind
of all there is to it are there are
there any other models that are missing
like how do you think about this like
simplifying this no I mean I I suppose
that you've got the passive income model
I think that's kind of what you're
alluding to and again there's a lot of
people who have sold the dream by
influencers out there about you know
building passive income but passive
income is based on it on active income
yeah where does active income come from
products and services
basically so always
you know all the roads lead back to that
basically so I I don't I don't believe
there are any other models out there
yeah
um no nice I like it I think it really
simplifies things okay so I've been
working with you and we've said and I've
said to you Robin right you know the
these are my slides for my talk at
McKinsey and you're like hang on I think
you should put you put your picture at
the start you're telling me about this
thing called score app link down below
uh where I can build a scorecard or a
quiz or something and I'm like oh cool
and then we're like practicing the
presentation and stuff and then I go to
the session and I'm like you know we we
check in afterwards I message you on
WhatsApp or something and I'm like Robin
the session went great I've already got
three people at the end of it who came
up to me and who said that they wanted
my coaching Services yeah and at that
point I felt scared and I was like
um so I said I'll get back to them so
I've got their numbers yeah what what
happens next uh well there's nothing to
be um so again if that if if there's a
Fear Factor around that transaction
having to happen well let's see if we
can eliminate that from the process a
little bit so what what might be a bit
of a compromise there that you might
feel more comfortable with could it be
something like well maybe let's just do
a 30 minute chat see if it's a good fit
no that sounds good so like that phrase
let's see if we gel together let's see
if we can work together yeah you've got
a bit of data about them already and
that's a free chat it's a free chat some
some people you could pay some you could
charge for it if you wanted to a small
amount if you wanted to get commitment
but yeah given they've sat through like
a 40 minute presentation with you filled
out your scorecard you've already built
up a bit of trust they know you from
your YouTube channel for example they're
more than likely going to show up so
free chat takes all of the the risk out
of it yeah for both of you
um you still need a process for that
chat
um you know there needs to be some sort
of structure for that so you take the
person on a bit of a journey but
ultimately what you're looking for is
like that chat is a it's a qualification
process think of it as like an interview
they're interviewing you to see whether
they can work with you but you're also
interviewing them to see whether it's a
good fit okay and I I have a rule of
three for those those chats um three red
flags if I spot three things during that
conversation where I think Hmm not sure
about that
um and I'll try I'm gonna have to think
of some examples now just so you've got
something at this point of reference but
um it could be that
um
I don't know maybe they worked with
three dating coaches before and it
didn't work out oh okay that's
interesting Why didn't it work out is it
the day three it'd be unusual for them
to have found three of the worst dating
coaches and then not work out or is it
just a coincidence or is it them that
could be the problem and a lot of people
don't like making it about the client
necessarily but we want we want to focus
on them and have their best interests at
heart we don't want to take their money
if there's going to be no chance of them
meeting the love of their life at the
end of it right yeah uh that's the right
thing to do what other red flags could
there be it could be if like all the way
through that chat like how much they
cost how much does it cost how much does
it cost how much they cost how much they
cost and you and and you want to Pace
them you could either be transparent and
just give them the price and say
but how I would position that is
I'm going to give you the price but
we're still going to go through a
process on this course you get value
from it and at the end of it I want you
to tell me yes or no whether you feel
that that's a fair exchange whether that
you think that's good value for money
and whether we're going to work together
or not
but don't choose to buy this product
purely based on price
in front yeah and you need to give them
the price okay
um so we can't again there's Rules of
Engagement there but I'd kind of be
thinking okay why are they so desperate
because it might be that maybe they're
they're speaking to three dating coaches
yeah and I'd be like okay well can I be
the last one you speak to yeah uh and
the reason for I'd want to be the last
one is because that now they've got all
of the information from the other two
and they're going to get some more
information from me they have everything
they need to know now to make a decision
yeah and I can help them make that
decision
even if it's going and working with one
of my competitors because they're going
to get better results with Steve who
works with people just like you yep like
this isn't a good fit yeah that's okay
that's a good result Steve is a joke
you're a jock yeah
identity layer we're back to Identity
layer we just don't think it's a good
fit yeah cool okay
um but that could be a red flag
um and that there's others as well it
could be they want to rush the process
maybe they're like I have to meet
somebody next week because I'm going to
a wedding like this cannot fail right
um that's not how we work this is a six
month process we're going to take you
through yes we have had some people
who've done it quickly so all the way
through the process you're kind of
managing expectations you're also
they'll be raising concerns you're
addressing their concerns
um some people call those objections I
don't objections a bit harsh like hard
yeah uh normally it's like people if
it's genuine people are just raising
their concerns how do you address
concerns you have a conversation about
it yeah just chat yeah nice okay so I do
these calls
um I do my 30 minute session and of this
like of the three two of them are like
at the end of it what do I say at the
end of it I'm like
you know we've gone through this process
and presumably I
so if I was working with you one-on-one
we'd figure out the process together but
like if someone's listening to this and
it's not working with you on one uh are
there any books that will teach me about
this process how does it work
is this like a is it technically like a
sales call so like books about sales
would be the thing yeah so um uh just
trying to now I'm trying to think of
some sales good sales good qualities or
like people who do sales training yeah
there's a guy called
um Benjamin dahaney um he's a he's an
Aussie guy he he's got a big beard and
it wears a bright red baseball cap nice
um uh so he's worth checking out so he
he does a lot of like Telly sales type
training and um just how he sort of
introduces the conversation but B also
pitches the offer and deals with
objections the types of questions he
asks
um I mean a lot of it's like Hamming it
up for you know social media and things
like that but actually there's a lot of
Truth in in the way that he positions
the conversations
um so he's excellent there's another guy
called David the sales Angel who is also
brilliant as well to follow
um
um uh he's a bit more hard-nosed
sometimes but what he one of the nice
things is and I don't know how ethical
this is but he does record his um like
live record his sales conversations he
has with prospects his own prospects for
his business yeah so he's actually
having real life conversations with
people and again how he sort of um
positions
um you know crossing the chasm from A to
B you know Gap selling and that sort of
thing it's brilliant yeah I mean if
selling is a brilliant book and even if
people just like search I'm just search
sales training on YouTube and there's
just loads of stuff yeah Chris Chris doe
also talks about an amazing um book
called Socratic selling
um which is again very conversational
you imagine like Socrates it's a
philosophical approach to asking good
questions basically that was a really
old school book yeah you can't get it as
I don't think it's not an audio book for
sure I think it's only a hardback which
is perfect the alpha is in the books
that are not available on Kindle these
days yeah
this is great okay we'll put links to in
the show notes and the video description
to all of this stuff it's exciting
um
and then I guess
the client starts with me and I've got
my day job on the side I'm hopping on
the zoom calls with them
and I'm sort of making it up as I go
along presumably well you've got your
sort of seven step you know framework
which Loosely you're kind of working too
yeah
coaching has a bit of flow to it so
sometimes the client might show up with
a bit of a curveball you know something
which has happened from one week to the
next which you have to address yeah you
know and work through with them so it
might be that but you know over the
course of the the six months you're
going to make sure that Loosely you
stick to the plan and get them to work
through each of those steps in your
seven step process nice
I remember I I launched um
so I I I've been coaching for seven
years I cut my cloth doing one to one
for three of those first the first three
years and then I I got busy just too
much demand so I was like right I've got
to go group
um but the time that was the the only
option I saw is it sore of it
so I think it was 2018 I did my launch
uh in I started the launch in October
by end of November I had 24 people
signed up my goal was to get the first
cohort of 30 people into the group and
um so I got 24 people signed up and then
I had to take
um break over Christmas and then I was
like damn I'm starting this thing on the
1st of January and I haven't built
anything yet sorry because I had this
idea in my head of I wanted I didn't
want it to just be me talking because
you know you when you when people learn
you have to get the different modalities
down so audio visual kinesthetic so if
it's just me talking it's it's just
audio visual it hasn't got any of the
kinesthetic stuff in there so I wanted
to have a portal I wanted to have a
really a decent workbook and various
things like that so I literally had to
lock myself in a room for five days
between Christmas and a year my wife
hated me that week
um and and just build the damn thing it
just had to be done
um and I think again this is where a lot
of people get tripped up they're like I
I've got to build the perfect product
before I launch anything like I can't
possibly I've got to cover everything
off and I was like well so I locked
myself in the room for for five days did
the shot all of the videos I built the
workbook I got quite ill in the process
as well because I've pushed myself like
way way too hard but I got the job done
um and sure enough I started delivering
the thing and then there was two or
three modules where people just like no
this doesn't work Robin because I asked
for honest feedback and they're like
these videos just don't work this
worksheet doesn't work so I was like
cool okay we'll change them we'll drop
them out there was two or three things
that were just neglected we just haven't
planned for during you know when I
designed the thing in that short period
of time
um so structuring in a way that was
adaptable that we could just add bits in
tape bits out you know and make it work
better
um worked really well if you try and
I've seen so many business owners who
spend months and months and months
designing the ultimate like program or
course or product or whatever it is and
then look they launched the thing
and then there's crickets and I get like
it's quite disappointing
um you know
um Eric Eric Reese wrote a great book
The Lean Startup where he talks about
creating a minimum viable version of it
so if you could create 80 of the end
products but in the shortest possible
time
um what would that look like
then let's say you know if your product
if you'd spent 12 months designing it
well if we could build that first MVP in
a month and then launch it and get a few
early adopters onto it going back to
Simon's the next thing
um and we get some feedback and we
improve it and then we a month later we
get some feedback and Improvement we get
a few more people so we're we're
building our audience as we grow yeah
we're improving the product as we go so
that rather than
you know getting to like this point you
know start here get to here so we've had
a little bit of an improvement on our
our product with just one cycle if we've
had 12
feedback loops happen during that time
your products are going to be like way
better
plus because you've been building an
audience as you go when the products
reached its like beta level and we're
ready to launch you've got a pre-built
audience to go right here's my thing
and I see so many business owners who
yeah the product's great like don't get
me wrong products brilliant but they've
put no time into building an audience
and sometimes it's like chicken and egg
which do you do first yeah I'm very much
in the build the audience
um whatever that looks like if you could
I don't know get a Facebook group to
like 500 to 1000 people
then do a product launch yep and you've
got that pre-built warm audience to then
launch something into yep
I found a couple things I want to talk
about uh what are the the biggest
mistakes you see people make on like in
the early stages of the entrepreneurial
Journey
um so I mean our hourly rates we've
talked about
um comparisonitis like the moment you
can pay yourself to other people like
again it it
um you things start to creep in like
imposter syndrome you start to
self-doubt you start to
um one of the things you mentioned oh
you know there's people out there and
they're doing it they're absolutely
killing it off so why me
um but that's actually going to stop you
from starting anything like you if if
you don't even uh what was the famous
quote you miss 100 of the shots you
don't take it was I can't remember who
that was by but
um it's that sort of philosophy so the
best thing you do everybody has
something unique to offer
um like think about it you know there's
hundreds of thousands of business books
out there so why should I write another
business book well it's because it's
it's me it's Unique you're writing a
book you know there's going to be
something unique in that that book you
know that only you're able to kind of
convey your message in your own unique
way
um so comparisonitis is like the death
of most entrepreneurs
um and it's I get it it's it's quite
hard you know to face up to the fact
that there's going to be challenges and
potential failures knockbacks it's going
to be hard work and things like that but
um less less not like stop before we've
even got started basically
one thing that people struggle with is
yeah just to this point you know oh you
know why would anyone sign up to my
relationship coaching business there are
other relationship coaches out there
with more experience who are charging
less or maybe charging more but whatever
that thing might be
um and if I were starting this
relationship business from scratch I
would be feeling a lot of imposter
syndrome because I'd be like
yeah I don't have all the clients that
these people have so how might I
approach that if I were thinking about
it how much do you want it to work
a lot a lot like 100 I'm all in like
let's I'm just gonna go for it anyway I
know that I know that these things are
there these challenges these worries are
there and they're real
but can I see myself just working
through that I guess the fear that would
hold me back is this thing of what if it
doesn't work okay imagine in 12 months
time it's worked
well yeah then my life would have
changed okay and what book in 12 months
time what does that business look like
what's giving you the confidence to for
it to have worked
if I can land even five clients Five
Points okay so there we go so five
clients well what's what's the root five
clients just our first client okay so
there's these little
um they're they're called okrs
objectives and key results right
um amazing book so I'm it's like a
library recommendation measure what
matters absolutely
um objectives and key results that's
what okr stands for and the idea is that
you have one overarching objective and
then there's a series of key results
which kind of lead you they give you
little signals that we know we're on
track to achieve achieve our objective
so if you if your goal is to have a
successful you know dating coaching
business
um which is making 25k a year and it's
got 10 clients in it well step number
one is a client
step number 0.5 is to go and have one of
those first five conversations chats
that we talked about
I should have started with step three
step number naught Point naught one is
like to go and pick yourself forward to
go and do one of the talks so it's like
there's these little steps you know that
you're kind of on track so reminding
yourself
um about the the smallest First Step uh
the second thing is also it's I call it
the truths exercises reminding yourself
what you know to be true about you so
Ali and this is this is really hard as
an exercise but
um list off 10 things that you know are
true about you I know yeah right now
okay 10 Things I know are true about me
yeah are we talking I mean like anything
like business mail yeah I'm five foot
eleven and a half but I go by six foot
one on hinge obviously
um
I enjoy playing video games so I don't
make much time for it I enjoy reading
books I have a YouTube channel I uh have
a podcast I
went to medical school I vaguely enjoyed
working as a doctor
I uh used to play chess and would like
to get more into it I like playing the
guitar I love musical theater and Ed
Sheeran and Taylor Swift
um I'd like to release an album of songs
one day
cool I think that's about 10. yeah at
least uh and you could probably come up
with 100 different things a thousand
different things which you know to be
true about you and the thing is nobody
can take those away you own those things
they are like truths about you right
um and so alongside that there was a
journey the makeup of you made those
truths happen
um in 12 months time what do you want to
be true about you I'd like to be a
published author
um I'd like to have written a book I'm
proud of I'd like to have shored up the
foundations of the business I'd like to
have lived in Austin for a bit you know
a few things like that okay so one one
little tweak to that is the language
which you used so you said I'm going to
I'm going to So when you say I'm going
to it kind of gives you permission to
kind of put it off that's the feature
okay so when you're creating future
truths you have to treat them like
they've already happened to call so you
just change the language that I have I
am cool yeah I'm a published author
um I have lived in Austin for a few
months
um I've written a book I'm proud of I am
I am currently working on my second book
uh I have built my business in uh sort
of central operationally effective way
Etc yeah there you go so that that's
Ali's identity in 12 months time that's
that's who you are okay
um I encourage everybody to I call it my
morning formula although ironically I
only ever read it in the afternoon when
I have a break my afternoon break
um but literally I have a list of like
100 truths all those things both future
ones and except pre-existing ones I know
are true about me whenever I have the
element that moment of self-doubt I go
back to that and I look at the Legacy
which I built up and I look at who I am
as in my makeup my identity everything
um and it makes me feel good
am I more or less likely to do stuff
when I feel good more likely to do more
likely yeah yeah you're going to see
those challenges that you might see as
challenges they're going to be just
you're just going to have taken the edge
off it by just giving yourself a little
boost of self-confidence and self-worth
because these things are true can't be
taken away from you
um and that often just helps to people
just to get started with doing something
the other thing as well is even if you
have a go at those things nobody can
ever take those trees away from you
because you've already got them they
can't go anywhere right
[Music]
um and
and 12 months time
uh the future version of Ali is thanking
today's Ali for doing something
to create these Future Truth what is
that
um
12 month old is definitely thanking
president daily for going to the gym
more regularly yeah in fact every day
because I've realized that if I do it
every other day that
like I think every day is easier than
every other day in a way
um future early 12 months from now I was
definitely thinking present daily for
for doing daily daily writing as like a
a habit and sticking with it because
everything is Downstream of writing when
it comes to the business yeah yeah yeah
it's a good exercise it's a really
powerful exercise yeah um whenever
whenever my clients experience those
little bits of self-doubt we just write
truth exercise so let's get into it nice
I love it
um why is your business called Fearless
like what does that mean there's a
there's a backstory uh it was a bit of a
happy accident so I was I started off
life as uh well Robin white and then
Robin went the business coach
um and then I went to deliver a talk in
front of about 60 people and somebody
asked me
um what's the thing that stops people
from achieving their goals and I said
well fear basically business owners need
to fear the little things in life
business ever so slightly less that stop
them achieve achieving their goals and
one of my one of my best mates in
business is is listening in the audience
and he literally stood up in the middle
of my talk he pointed at me and he went
The Fearless business coach and so
that's where Fearless came from it's
about fearing those little things in
life ever so slightly less that stop us
from stepping out and achieving
something so it's you know a 60 second
Pitch again there's like the worst case
scenario you fluff it up and
you walk out the room
nobody cares right it's just like you
can't let those little tiny little
things stop you nice
what's your biggest challenge right now
when it comes to the business oh great
question
um
so
my biggest challenge is time and this is
a bit of
um I didn't realize when I had kids how
much of an impact it would have on my
life yeah and not not I don't mean that
in terms of like they take up loads of
time it's just
uh there's a big shift in everything
like perspective wise
um and so I kind of with my businesses I
played all out as doing all lighters I
was all sorts of things just um crazy
stuff just to make my businesses work
and then
um pops and stuff come along and
immediately it's like life gets turned
upside down and you realize kind of
really what the important things in life
about and I know that's like totally
cliched but equally what what that means
is that um there has to be compromise
along the way and I've chosen to have a
slower pace of life with my business in
order to be able to make sure that I'm
not compromising on the time that I get
to spend with my girls and that does
mean a little bit my personal goals get
they're not they're not eradicated I
think a lot of people make the mistake
you have kids and things to stop like
personally wise they're by no means gone
but the process of writing a book
becomes that just a little bit harder
because it takes a bit longer
you know
kids well my kids not everybody's kids
do this hopefully but my kids for
example from knowing you wake up in the
morning it's all about school runs you
know it's um I get probably six hours
during the day when they're at school if
I'm lucky pick them up tea time bedtime
everything else and right now they're
not going to bed till 10 o'clock at
night so it's not like I can hustle
harder and go out to my office at 10
o'clock and write a thousand words it's
like I'm beat at that point yeah and I
think it's that fighting against the I
mean this is right I mean I'm only 41
I'm a long way from being over the hill
yet but this is why footballers retire
at 41 I've got that whole male body sort
of slowing down thing at sort of 41 not
feeling like I'm I have to push myself
harder to be at my optimal so going to
the gym cycling stuff that I have to
work a little bit harder just to keep
fit uh I'm feeling quite tired and I've
got the precious of kids there's just
this stuff that's just going on that
you know
that there's times when I look back on
sort of my 20s when I was growing my
business pre-kids and I had all the time
in the world I don't think I optimized
my time enough in my 20s yeah to be set
up right to have kids or 30s okay
what advice would you give me um I've
just turned 29 and I don't have kids yet
but hoping during the next few years
um
God that's it's it's so personal I think
I think I I I I mean it's hypothetical
because it is what it is my my truths
are I have I have kids right and the
business is set the way that it is but
um I think I probably would have built
um a business that had more sustainable
recurring Revenue coming in Faster I
left it probably not not long but I left
it probably three or four years too late
so in the agency we we did web design we
did hosting and actually my business's
valuation was based on the hosting and I
wish I got to work building that Revenue
four years earlier
I I wouldn't have sold it
hmm because a cash flow would have been
just too good okay interesting and that
and that I but I certainly don't regret
it as a massive lesson which I've
learned and and I bring a great amount
of that learning into well one into my
current business now or two businesses
which I run
um but also now I'm able to help my
clients not make that it's a mistake
like you know I'm like cool accelerate
accelerate your recurring Revenue
and do it fast nice
that's that's a good tip yeah that's a
good tip uh anything else
while we're on the topic
um well you're kind of you're kind of
doing it already like going to the gym
like every day again I wish I'd focused
on my fitness and health so that when I
had kids and I knew that my time was
going to be slightly less yeah
um uh I wouldn't have to fight so hard
when I got to the gym because like you
go into an optimal sort of Fitness yeah
you have less Fitness to lose if that
makes it you know it's hot it's harder
to keep maintain that Fitness whereas at
the moment I kind of feel again like I'm
playing catch up
um well they granted I had an operation
on my ankle like in October so yeah got
excuses for not getting on the bike but
they are excuses I'm back on the bike
now but it's it's just that recovery
time again it's just that much so if you
start
in an optimal Place yeah pre-kids it's
easier to maintain I believe
so you're an Entre like you know there's
a question I've been asking people
recently um you know you're an
entrepreneur you like the freedom fun
flexibility that the entrepreneur life
gives you otherwise you probably
wouldn't have started a business
how does that how does that desire for
optionality and Freedom Square with
having a wife and kids
so it's really interesting actually so
my
my whole I mean this is this goes back
to this it's quite a deep question Ali I
mean how how far do you want to go in
the podcast yeah
um
so all of my childhood growing up was
watching my mum and dad like work so
incredibly hard everything was all about
you've got to work hard to earn your
money to put a roof over your head to
pay the mortgage put food on every you
know the story all of the arguments
they're about money like there was there
was a
um it was very much like all about work
in our household and
um
uh so there's a part of me which is
that's my that's my story that's my
pattern I go back to is it's I have to
work hard that's what gets the results
and I've probably spent the last 20
years or 19 years running my businesses
unpacking all of that and creating a new
story and the type the times in my life
now where
it feels easy and effortless don't
involve work
but it goes against my better nature
because it's always included work so
when I'm not working I'm constantly like
I get the work guilt still
like certainly nowhere near where I was
like five ten plus years ago yeah
um
you know when I'm sat out
on my seats looking over the Cotswold
Hills yeah sipping a beer
occasionally I get the nagging little we
should be working
and you don't need to
at the start of this year I made a very
firm commitment to myself that
everything would be easy and effortless
less is more I would make very conscious
decisions about what projects I would
undertake what Partnerships I would form
I was very intentional about who I would
work choose to work with this year
client wise marketing wise everything
and not work very hard
I'm the happiest I've been in a
told you to go deep yeah
how was the balance between like work
and life I guess before this year like
last couple of years it was just
frenetic like mental
mental crazy and this is actually it
makes it really hard because I know that
like right now for example I know that
my wife is still still working so damn
hard and I wanted to see this
opportunity this life which I'm kind of
starting to peek and see inside of
um she's a lawyer basically she just
works incredibly long hours she's
recently kind of got a sideways
promotion but just so much more pressure
and um
I don't know you realize that there's
just more to life I think than
work and money and stuff like that
um the biggest challenge though and this
I think this is where sort of a lot of
the emotion comes from is that because
my childhood has always been about work
it's hard not to fall into that with the
relationship between my my girls I don't
know because I because I
say my relationship between mum and dad
was all about work yeah
it's the Apple Falls from not far from
the tree it's I play and play that out
sometimes I get caught up in the work
story and I have to be very very
conscious about not getting caught up in
that story and creating a new story for
my children hmm it's hard it takes
probably out of everything that's what
requires the most amount of work
what does that look like like what's a
what does that look like when we're
playing playing out that story well work
is serious isn't it it's like very
focused it takes all of your attention
away right but with kids
it's fun playful
it's exploratory it's like
um
Dancing Yeah I don't know it's all you
can imagine all the fun stuff the stuff
that went through our minds when we were
kids that we've forgotten about there
are kids my kids are now
you know want to enjoy in life
and it's it's being able to get involved
in that yeah without being drawn into
the work serious thing just stay in the
fun playful space for them yeah
so is the guilt around it from like uh
if I'm if I work harder then I'll make
more money and therefore be able to give
the kids a better life is that is that
the pattern or is that the script like
what's what's the script that's like my
challenge Alice I love what I do I love
my work yeah it's a different kind of
love though obviously to family and kids
and all that sort of stuff but it's it's
I'm so passionate about helping the
business owners but but you but then am
I just using that as an excuse to get
more tied up in work and ignore what I
need the work I need to be doing over
here with my family right it's it's a
it's it's such a complicated battle
um which you know it's it's a lifetime's
worth of like stuff that's got me caught
up in that which I'm now probably
spending the next part of my lifetime
unpacking yeah when I when I project my
life out into the future I can very much
see a world in which my default is work
and
there's a good book um how will you
measure your life by Clayton Christensen
I think yeah yeah where are you talking
about like how
for most people who are sort of I mean
he I think is like a Harvard Business
School Professor or something and so
people in that sort of camp
uh Harvard MBA students but also like
entrepreneurs and stuff
you know when you look back on your life
a couple of decades from now the thing
that they all basically do is over
invest in their work and under invest in
their health and relationships yeah and
it's just such a common pattern and I'm
like I need to fight fight really hard
against that inertia it's PR it's
provider traits I think we've done it
since we were cavemen yeah you know that
that's it's it's a it's a natural
instinct but
we don't have to do that in 2023 hmm
um I there's there's a whole other
episode and probably people who are
better educated to speak about this than
me but the whole sort of equality male
female equality and and this you know
everything which goes along with that
um
it's just you know I I think it's about
um being open to just break breaking
those sort of
um like the provider trait is I think
it's quite toxic
in men because quite often men absorb
themselves in their work I've done this
I've been totally guilty of this I don't
mind not ashamed to admit it while
probably slightly shameful to admit it I
don't know
but um sometimes I've used workers as a
reason to hide from problems challenges
in my life whatever shape or form those
take
um and I that's the toxic side of it and
I think if men become more aware this is
going off in a proper tangent now right
if if men become more aware
of the reasons why they're turning to
work yeah uh and they're they're able to
face that reality that maybe they might
be hiding away from something with their
work
uh we will have a lot more happier men
out there I think in the long run if
they can start to understand that damn
as you're saying that I'm thinking like
[__] what am I hiding from
yeah because I think especially as an
entrepreneur it's easy to sell yourself
the story of like I enjoy the I enjoy my
work yeah
um I was uh I happened to spend spend a
few hours with a guy called Bill Perkins
last week he's said this like
ridiculously wealthy hedge fund manager
in in Texas he's written a book called a
die with zero which is about how to make
the most from your money and from your
life
and I asked him you know one thing he
said was that most
rich people don't understand money
because they keep on working for it even
though it comes at the expense of
they're like family or the friends their
their hobbies and things like that and
I'm like okay come on but like what
about the people who say they enjoy
their work and he was like well you know
a crackhead would say they enjoy crack
addict enjoys heroin it's the same kind
of thing I was like huh
interesting
because I guess like there there is that
balance right because if you do
genuinely enjoy your work but you also
want to spend time with the family and
stuff then there's that natural tension
that's there again I'm I talked about
binary thinking so there's this thing
about uh work not work yeah but within
work if we can see that there's
different degrees of it so uh coach like
you you've seen me work coach right 10
out of 10 for me I'm I'm all in like I
just didn't I love it so much and I
because I know one that the impact that
it's creating for clients but it's my
flow space that's when I get into my
my natural that's my happy Lego Space if
you like
um uh there's other bits of the business
that I can leave it or take it sales I
enjoy because it's still coaching
um marketing when I'm doing stuff like
this like I'm in Flow State again to it
um speaking on stage things like that so
if if you can fill your work life up
with all of those things that are 10 out
of 10 and then anything which falls
short of that which you can compromise
and give to somebody else yeah obviously
bearing in mind what we've talked about
numbers and things like that but the
other bits of the business
um it's okay to if it if you only need
to spend four hours
doing that amazing awesome stuff that
really fills you up gives Great Value to
the people around you and the other 36
hours of the week that you would
ordinarily use to hide yep yep
give that to somebody else you've got 36
hours back now to learn something new
about yourself
with all this in mind
it sounds like I mean both you and I are
quite bullish on entrepreneurship as a
career because of the F that it unlocks
the freedom fun flexibility fulfillment
etc etc Finance but those benefits you
know any any vote you take into excess
can become a vice yes
a given like given your experience in
entrepreneurship now for the last like
20 years I guess
if
Poppy and Sophie were like Dad we want
to be entrepreneurs
would you be like yes or would you be
like uh I think again
I I'd probably be like don't don't
mistake entrepreneurship for work or
vice versa okay what do you mean uh so
if you're gonna step out and do
entrepreneurship
um don't put yourself through the
mince it basically it should be easy and
effortless and do something you love
doing and it should provide a life for
you that and not just money but a life
for you that you want to it's like icky
guy you know like the Japanese sort of
um framework isn't it the four pillars
of Vicky guy
um what's it Mission passion vocation
and purpose something or something
similar to that
um you know if you if you get all of
those four pillars right you can have a
great life help amazing people earn some
good money you know it it all you
achieve Vicky guy
um which I think is I think that
translates roughly and I'm going to
completely get this wrong but it's the
state of flow in your life
um
so that would be the route which I would
take with them if I saw them working too
hard yep I'd probably step in and say
you're working too hard you don't need
to work so hard let's try and find a
more easy and effortless way for you to
do this so easy and effortless goes
against the grain of most the hustle and
grind culture is [__] I'm sorry to
swear but it's it's all complete BS
there's times when you've got it you
have gotta work hard yeah but it does
not all if you're doing that too much
it's toxic it's the it falls into that
um
what you're saying about sort of
alcoholism and stuff like that
um and I think that's touted about too
much way too much hmm that's what it's
what basically everyone everyone who
interview on this podcast says they're
they're all like oh yeah you know it's
all about work-life balance I wish I
hadn't worked so hard
but that's easy enough to say when
you've already got a successful business
and I often I like to ask like
do you think you could have built the
business that you've had like the agency
and the coaching business and and the
apps and stuff
would there would there have been a way
of doing it while also enjoying the
journey along the way and like being
chill about it and stuff I'm it's gonna
sound awful mentors mentors coaches
books podcasts YouTube videos like
lifelong learning
the again mistake I made I finished uni
and I've been doing little businesses
and things along the way yeah I finished
uni and I thought that's it I don't need
to read books anymore and I didn't read
books for six or seven years in the
first few years of my business and I
bitterly regret that I think what I what
I've learned from the connections I've
made and the books I've read and things
like that
I I actually wish I hadn't gone to UNI
in the first place and I'm not suggest
that's not a suggestion for anybody to
skip uni right there's there's some
value in that it's one of my truths I
have a business management degree hey
that's that's got some value to it
um but that said I think if I'd started
a business at 18 if I'd had a good idea
I don't I think I lacked the idea then
that's why I didn't go for it and I
didn't have parents who were in The
entrepreneurial space to push me the
internet was very young so we didn't
have all these influences out there that
are out there but like people in 2023
don't have any excuses you can you can
listen to any amount of podcasts get as
much business information as you want
for free or inexpensively you can get
any amount of mentoring and advice you
want for free or inexpensively didn't
have I know my thing is pricing and
let's raise the bar a little bit but the
entry point is low yeah you know get on
that train and start learning um
yeah that's so true
it has only about six or seven months
ago that I read my first ever book on
sales marketing I read.com Secrets by
Russell Brunson and I've been in
Russell's email list since the age of 13
but always thought it was a bit of a
camera so I just ignored all his emails
and then I read the book and I was like
oh my freaking God why didn't I read
this like freaking five six seven years
ago as soon as I started selling stuff
I've been selling stuff on the internet
for 10 years and making it up as I went
along for the last nine and a half and
I'm like oh
ah it starts to me it started to make
sense
um but I love that thing it's like what
Alex formosi says that you know you're
you're paying off ignorance debt yeah
fairly early on and one way to pay off
ignorance debt is to do the thing but
another way is to learn from people who
have made mistakes doing the thing yeah
while doing the thing and you just
accelerate your learning so so much
quicker and I think that that yeah
speaking to the the value of having a
coach having a mentor you know for me
business coaches CEO coaches have been
probably the single most Roi positive
expense yeah like throughout my entire
life because one of the things you know
the guy I work with these days Eric
who's going to feature on this podcast
soon
you know this whole thing is you know
his his coaching model is about you know
partly about the business partly about
leadership but also partly about
um health of the health of the person
um and so one of the okrs that we set is
me going to the gym next number of times
a week and that kind of stuff yeah
um because the health and relationship
stuff is so tied up with what makes a
good CEO and what makes a good leader
that I think we ignore that stuff at our
peril well I think Health full stop is
the most important I mean this isn't my
domain by the way yeah it's it's uh I
lead to help relatively Health I'll eat
while I go and exercise but surfing well
exactly
um but but like think about it if you're
if you're if you're unhealthy or you're
ill you're no use to anybody you can't
run a business you can't be a good
husband father to your kids can't look
after your parents when they're sick you
can't you can't do anything so health is
like Paramount it's the most important
thing to like focus on that's the one
so I'm gonna be heading to the gym
straight after this um can we talk a
little bit about the book and the kind
offer that you're you're extending our
listeners
uh what do you want to know um so what
is the book about uh so you know this is
this is your book take a shot this is uh
you know we we got to know each other
through a Zuma Mastermind and lockdown
yeah and then I heard you have this book
so I got the book and Kindle and I read
the book and I was like oh this is
giving me a firmware update about how to
think about business
um so what is the book about and what's
the deal with all these free copies we
have available yeah so uh look the books
actually so it's told us a parable and
it's only 100 pages so it's a nice short
sort of pithy tale about
um it's actually about a golf
professional but it could be about any
service business owner
um and actually how it came about so
it's based on the true story I I tell I
actually tell the story of my journey
working with this client and
um when I sold my agency I did did a
webinar which was designed for the web
design businesses basically to learn how
to build and sell their their businesses
and about 40 people on it and afterwards
I got the phone call from this very
excitable guy named Russ it's amazing
his best webinar I've ever been on I've
got so many questions or something else
oh cool so what do you do he's like I'm
a golf pro it's like my marketing
clearly failed but anyway so
um you know uh uh so we got chatting and
then actually he ultimately ended up
becoming one of my first clients um and
so I kind of tell his story about in in
the book about
um what it feels like to grow his
business the challenges the pain points
he has the struggles you go through and
I I won't give too much of a spoiler
alert on it but he meets a coach the
coach then helps him to restructure his
his program his golf you know lessons
and uh start to play out his dreams and
Ambitions that he had for himself his
life and for his family and things like
that so I'll I'll leave it so if anybody
reads it I'll leave it for you to figure
out who each of the characters are based
on within that story because there's
obviously various different characters
that play Parts you know in the story
I've kind of come into my life as well
um but in terms of the the offer um so
Ali and I are both going to sign uh 15
copies of the book
uh before I leave and so the first 15
people who apply so
um go and fill out the scorecard so I've
got a um a scorecard which I've created
to see how Fearless you are in business
uh which is just fearless.biz uh sorry
fearless.scoreapp.com yeah we'll put a
link in the show notes in the video
description perfect and then so the
first 15 people who um fill out the
scorecard and apply for a copy of the
book they'll get a signed copy of it
basically nice wherever they are in the
world except for South Africa everything
I've sent there has either been nicked
or it's been reviewed okay so any any
country in the world except South Africa
you will post them free copy of the book
yeah any strings attached to that nope
so you're just going to take the hidden
postage yep nice yeah absolutely they
can donate some beer money if they want
to to cover postage that's fine you know
um but if I just my my thing is all
about
um
you know not not everybody can afford
coaching
um books are one of the they've helped
me so much so I just wanna I made it a
thing that I want to give away like 50
to 100 copies of my book a month and I
don't care it's if that's a major part
of it yeah it's a bit in marketing but
also I know that those books help people
so it's my one of my little ways of of
giving back and I know people get value
from it
um you know I guess if people want to
help out they can leave a review if they
like it yeah hopefully a positive review
nice uh if there are more than 15 people
would you be open to giving the PDF to
the giveaway PDFs yeah oh nice because I
guess that that doesn't require the cost
of distribution kind of kind of
situation
um cool so we're only mentioning this at
the end of the episode so if you if you
currently are listening or watching to
this then you are the you know very few
people who've gotten to the end of the
episode so
um have a link have a look in the show
notes or in the video description and
we'll find we'll put a link to that
scorecard and then you'll either get a
free physical copy from Robin or you'll
get a PDF copy that's it yep love it
beautiful those are great thank you so
much my pleasure any any parting words
of wisdom for people who have gone this
far in the podcast well I I there's
probably quite a few people watching
this who maybe have started to think
about oh I've got an idea
um my advice is just don't overthink it
just get out there and just start it
take your shot love it thank you Robin
my pleasure all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye